So guys, Nick and Chud are fighting.
They've had their big fallout.
Obviously, they already fell out ages
ago really, but Nick didn't say anything
about it because he's total [__] But
uh they've actually fallen out now and
Chud leaked like a little bit
of a conversation they had where Nick
was crying to him in DMs about him
making jokes about people getting
blocked on Twitter while talking to
Pisco.
Do you guys remember that? If you guys
remember that classic clip
where Pisco says, "Nicholas Yuri blocked
me." And Chud says, "Oh yeah, he does
that
and they got very mad."
Now apparently there's some other secret
conversation that actually shows how
evil Chud is the next league. So let's
take a look. Sleepy here, Schley, not
Sleepy, that's a very different person.
Sleepy here has posted a 15minute video
going over some of the drama. So
hopefully that's going to recap most of
this for us.
>> For the last week or two, I've been
waiting for a certain someone to return
to streaming.
>> God damn it, man. I You've gotten too
powerful. It's time. You ready? Are you
ready for tomorrow when it's time to
take you down?
>> Yes, dude. What's tomorrow? [laughter]
>> Ch's coming back.
>> Oh.
>> Now, while Chud Logic was on vacation,
Nick Dioro decided to burn the bridge,
as they say. a bridge that at this point
had hardly existed and mainly served as
a way for Nick Dioro to get lighter
coverage from Chudlogic
>> little bit of while the cats away the
>> people like the toastify and people like
that and Aiden
>> play which to be honest with you I'm a
bit takenback by I didn't realize I was
that much of a risk or a threat that
people have got to cower away from me
and only say their peace when I'm away
and can't respond holy
>> and by people we're talking about one
person that name is Nick Dioro
>> Haven't you been a one-sided Cold War
Nick for over a year now. Well, you
think it's one-sided because you don't
see behind the scenes. You don't see the
angry messages that I get when I say
something out of pocket on stream. So,
it seems one-sided to you. It seems
one-sided to you, but it's not to me cuz
I get that little angry message. Um,
Chud Chud, um, you said this thing on
stream, Chud. Um, Chard, you just
released a video talking [__] about me,
Chud. That's not really trying to bring
the temperature down, is it, Chard?
>> Now, I think there's going to be some
time spent discussing the great sweep
where Nick Dioro was sweeping for Turkey
to Am I one to talk? No. But also, I
just don't think that that matters in
this situation as much as anything else.
At best, I'll say that it was a catalyst
for getting us to this point where Nick
Dioro felt comfortable to go after Chud
while Chud was on vacation. The thing
is, you can say that like Chud jumped
the gun and maybe made two firm
statements or something or it was like
rude to go after. I don't even know. But
it's built off of a history of that kind
of sweeping of them shutting down the
Kai stuff, telling people not to talk
about it, sping out a lot of people when
it gets brought up.
Uh the Willie Max stuff that Nick
refused to cover.
You know, there is a track record here
of shutting down
uh the stories that might be negative.
But to me, the story is more about Nick
Dioro continually isolating himself
further and further from any source of
criticism. One of perhaps the most
embarrassing examples of this is the
fact that he is somehow embarrassed that
he blocks people. Do you hear what I'm
saying? He makes the decision to block
people. And this blocking thing, like he
will block anyone. He blocks everyone,
honestly. Why did Nicholas Dioro block
me? I genuinely like the guy. Another
block. Another block. Another block.
Anyone who says anything remotely
negative gets blocked. Now, I I
definitely don't have time to go through
every Nick Dioro video and find a quote
of him saying it, but it's on his
Wikubia. Nick has no issue blocking
people on Twitter and finds it
entertaining to watch them make alt
accounts. I am sure I have heard him say
this before. I'm not going to find the
quote for you. My point in bringing this
up is Nicholas Dioro will block anyone
who has anything negative to say. If
they look at him wrong, he'll block you.
to Pisco. Do you remember that I made I
made some comments to Pisco about how
much Nick blocks people and that I felt
as strange.
>> I'm going to bring up that clip with
Pisco. People might be misremembering
that, but uh actually Pisco is the one
who brought that up, the whole blocking
situation. And guess what I got when
that started getting shared on social
media? I got an angry DM from Nicholas,
didn't I? I got an angry DM from
Nicholas. Nicholas was in my [__] ear
once again. Chud, I've tried to be your
friend. I've tried to message you. What
are these comments that you're making?
Right. And once again, I tried to play
the [__] Peacemaker cuz this is the
thing with Nicholas Dioro. Dude, this is
the problem. Okay. He wants to have a
private conversation to cool things
down. And I, to my discredit, criticize
me for all this if you want to. I've
allowed that to happen. And I've been
like, you know what? I do like Nicholas.
I do appreciate what he's done.
>> Private conversations about
disagreements and coverage are [__]
gay. It's [__] gay and embarrassing
to do that. If you're saying [__]
publicly, you get challenged on it
publicly. Totally embarrassing and lame
to keep it private. I understand if you
like talk to them in private anyway.
Like, you know, there's been plenty of
times where me and Aiden disagree about
something and we talk in private anyway.
So, it comes up and we end up having the
argument offstream. Not because we're
trying to keep it off stream, just
because we're both argumentative and
>> the audio grooming Aiden into tring and
turning on you and Chud as a honey trap
set for Chud in a few months from now as
the ultimate checkmate.
>> Thank you for the dono. Huge appreciate.
Thank you.
So yeah, so arguments might happen off
stream by, you know, chance just because
people have those conversations off
stream.
But the idea that you keep it off stream
to avoid a blow up or avoid looking bad
or whatever is just so lame. It's so
[__] lame. Done for me. I don't want
to get into some [__] fight over
this. Okay. [clears throat] Yes, I have
been a [__] I have been a [__] Call
me a [__] So when Chudlo Logic
mentions that Dioro blocks a lot of
people, okay, something that Dioro
openly talks about, Dioro gets, I guess,
embarrassed and goes to the DMs and
cries and whines like a little [__] to
Chud Logic.
>> Who are the commentary guys? This is
Nicholas Dioro.
>> Nick Dioro, Willie Mack show.
>> I learned who Nick Dioro was. He blocked
me. I've never spoken to this man in my
life.
>> Oh, he does that. He does that. Yeah, he
like
>> I haven't but I haven't talked to him.
>> Okay.
>> The reason he blocked him is just so
obvious. Pisco started questioning Ethan
Klein stuff. Pisco is competent.
That's enough. That's enough. Now it
help it it doesn't help that obviously
I've spoken positively of peace guy and
it is very clear that there is some uh
you know not to be not to be that guy
but it's very clear
there's some underlying feeling about me
somewhere in this
just based on uh who he mass blocked and
the way he acted for a very long time.
Um, so I don't think that helps. I think
me boosting Pisco uh to commentary
people is probably part of why he was
pretty much immediately blocked.
>> Okay.
>> I haven't said a word to this dude.
>> It's cuz he's worried of your great
legal knowledge, but he shouldn't be.
>> It's because he's worried because Pisco
is a pretty intelligent guy. He's a
lawyer and he's somewhat pro- Hassan. If
I'm being honest, that's probably why
Dioro blocked him. Let me just get out
ahead of this potential problem. Don't
need him quote retweeting my [__] I
mean, let's think about this clearly.
Why else would Dioro block Pisco?
They've never had an interaction. Chudlo
Logic seems comfortable talking to
Pisco. We know that a name that Dior
doesn't really
>> Doro likes uh Houdini. Is that is that
the name of the MM song? The recent one
that uses like the um
like [__] nostalgia [__] in the
music video.
The Oreo think that thinks that's that's
hard. Unironically,
>> likes Pisco. I'm really racking my brain
trying to come up with a reason that you
would block another content creator that
you've never interacted with, that you
have no beef with, just randomly. But
what's absolutely [__] incredible is
the idea that you would then go and
complain to Chud Logic that it was
brought up on his stream. Now, if you
watch a little bit further into this
clip, maybe maybe we find a reason why
Dioro had to DM Chud. Anyway, no, wait a
second. Sorry, dude. I thought of a
better joke and it's too late now. But
what I should have said to you when you
asked that, what have you done? You
failed to realize that Ethan Klein
always wins. [__] That would have been
so much better, dude. That would have
been so much better.
>> Oh [__] E [__] clients are doing
this.
>> It seems like Dioro is very much
sensitive with the characterization that
he's an Ethan Klein Cox leaf. Well over
75% of the content that Dioro puts out
is content about people that are quote
unquote enemies of Ethan Klein. You'll
find that he covers Hosanabi all the
time. Hosanabi I mean in fairness if you
want to say that his political coverage
is bad. Okay, he's a hypocrite for his
uh socialist takes but his capitalist.
>> So it was a terrible moment to be a
logic head. I just it's like one of
those times where I just wish you know
this [__] would just calm down. Do you
know what I mean? It was just so
painful. They were so close to having
the actual conversation. This guy just
kept spazzing out for the whole [__]
debate. So disappointing.
>> Lifestyle. I'm sure you can find your
reasons to criticize someone like
Hosanabi. I mean, Dioro has found the
ability to put out one to two to three
to 4hour videos every week for the last
six, seven months. And look, I'm not
saying everything needs to be measured
in terms of polarity here, but while
covering Hassanabi, a notable political
content creator, in the last 6 months,
there's not a single video about Asmin
Gold. Peculiar. Very interesting. Very
interesting. I'd argue Asmin Gold, if
you're so, you know, worried about
online political content creators is
significantly worse. It makes me
question why Dioro is only targeting one
side of Twitch's political content
creation. And not only is he only
targeting one side, but he's targeting
arguably the smaller side, as Amin Gold
currently has a bigger audience. There's
one of two reasons. Either A, he doesn't
want to upset the right-wing Chuds in
his audience that support him every time
he goes against Hosanabi, or B, he
doesn't want to upset Ethan Klein, who
has recently formed something of an
alliance with Asmin Gold after getting
Casey Tron to apologize to Asmin Gold
for implicating him in his mother's
death. Quick note, Asmin Gold was
purchasing cigarettes for his mother who
had COPD using an oxygen tank. She lit
one of those uh cigarettes right next to
the oxygen tank, went up in flames, and
later died from complications. Happens,
you know. Personally, I think it's a mix
of the two because I think Dioro is
purely financially motivated. I don't
think that this guy has any backbone,
spine, or any interest in actually
spreading a message that he cares about.
If you're a Nicholas Dioro stream
viewer, you're not watching Nicholas
Dioro provide true opinions or feelings
or whatever the [__] What you're
actually watching, thank you for the $5,
GBY.
>> Cigarette emoji. Cigarette emoji.
Cigarette emoji. Cigarette emoji.
Cigarette emoji.
>> Thank you, Kubby. Is a content creator
that's completely lost their sense of
self. You're watching an Ethan Klein
weather vein. Every day, Nicholas Dioro
wakes up and he goes on to the H3
podcast channel and he goes, "What did
they talk about today?" An Italian from
Long Island is having his bread buttered
by two Jews in California. It's
something that Dioro loves to bring up
in much of his content is that he's not
a politics streamer, okay? He only
concerns himself with drama. It's
exactly why he brings up anti-semitism
every time he talks about Hassan.
>> Did you know Morgie Morgan is actually
friends with Assan [__] who hates Jews
and loves abusing his animals? I hate
>> now as somebody who calls himself an
>> I mean that was kind of he was sort of
like mocking think before you sleep
there but he would say the same [__]
>> He literally says all the same [__]
>> Thank the membership. Thank you.
>> A political streamer. Why would you why
would you just say that? Why would you
openly say that Hassan is an
anti-semite? Would you call someone like
Ethan Klein Islamophobic if they said
Islamophobic things? I'm calling
>> Ela, are you sure we're going the right
way?
>> You know what they say? You know what
they say, follow the Allah Akbars. On
the other hand, acknowledge that like I
think per capita a lot of the weird
[__] terrorism and crimes and [__] I
mean there's definitely some [music]
strong thread of violence through that.
Muslim community or Arab Muslims to be
more specific.
>> Some of the statements there could be
categorized as Islamophobic. I think
that goes without saying. But you're
smoking crack if you think that Nick
Dioro would ever point that out. But of
course, if we're discussing Hassan, even
if he's not said anything anti-Semitic,
we're going to categorize him as such
because he's he's just an anti-Semitic
guy. Okay. Can't believe he's covering
the genocide in Gaza right now. That's
like super anti-Semitic. What the [__]
They just make embarrassing terrible
arguments about it, too.
>> Dude, literally remember, Dude, it's so
funny Nick acts like he like never
engaged in politics. It's like, remember
when those [__] two uh what were
they? It was like they were embassy
workers at a
Jewish or Holocaust museum at an event
hosted by some kind of like iffy Zionist
uh think tank or some [__]
And that guy shot two. They shot two of
them.
And Nick's posting like immediately like
how it's like an anti-semitic hate
crime, how Hassan's excusing the murder
or whatever the [__] justifying the
murder. And it was like you go look at
the clips and he absolutely was not
doing that.
It was just like totally embarrassing.
This guy just like totally spazzed out
and went into a full JN meltdown. K
caught JN. Went into a full meltdown.
You're supposed to be pro- Israel. But
again, this isn't about Assan. This
isn't about Ethan Klein. This is about
Nick Dioro being a weather vein for
Ethan Klein. And when you decide to do
that, when you decide to follow, you
know, the whims of another content
creator who has their own enemies and is
deeply disliked by a lot of people and
gets themselves into controversy and
drama all the time. Well, if you're
going to defend them at every
>> Oh, yeah. Wasn't you? The uh the
healthcare shooting was New York. That
one was DC, right?
>> Step. You're going to build some
enemies. You're going to build some
resentment towards you. And also, if
you're going to be extremely successful
at it, let's let's be clear, he's been
very successful at it. He's probably
made the most money he's ever made. He's
had the highest viewership he's ever
had. People see that exposure, they see
why it's happening, and they take
notice. And when people take notice,
they're more likely to see your bias,
and they're more likely to call you out
on it. And that's where you get guys
like Queen, you get guys like Chudlo
Logic Logic obviously being a bit of a
Johnny come lately, but hey, he's leaked
some DMs today. I just saw a clip of you
saying, "I don't like you anymore, but
you haven't answered a DM from me since
September." LMAO, I did try to keep
comms open. Hey man, yeah, I've had a
lot on and honestly, it's difficult to
know what the deal is. We have gone our
separate ways in many ways, and
obviously it does feel a bit [__] that
no one really likes me anymore from the
commentary space. I do probably have
issues with some of your coverage, but I
don't want to keep talking about EHD.
And honestly, I have always appreciated
you and the things you have done for me.
So, I make snarky jabs from time to time
to signal that I disagree, but I don't
want to blow up what little bridge we
have left by going full skitso mode and
attacking you. I guess I feel a strange.
Haha. To me, the reading of that is
really easy. Hey, Nick, you did some
good things for me, but I think you're a
[__] [__] now. I don't agree with
any of your coverage, and in order to
not blow up the bridge and make you look
bad, I'm just doing little jabs here and
there rather than making a full expose
on things that I don't like about your
coverage. Just to be perfectly
transparent, this conversation soured my
perception of you. I have many friends
in the online ecosystem I disagree with
slash make different content than me.
This was never an issue. Despite this, I
did attempt to keep the bridge open
regardless. What friends in the
ecosystem does Dioro have that he
disagrees with slash makes different
like make different content? Nobody
cares about making different content. I
imagine the only people he's friends
with online are people that make
different content than him. Genuinely,
what live streamer, what what daily
content creator is friends with Nick
Dioro? If you don't agree with this
Ethan Klein dick suck take. Friendship
over. So yeah, I mean that backs up the
feeling of feeling estranged. Haha. It's
all good. I'm not mad or anything.
Things change. People do different
things, etc. Listen, man. Not everything
has to be some catastrophic breakdown.
Haha. I know you were used to that.
Yeah, man. Good luck with whatever
you're doing over there. What a snarky
[__] bro. And then this is Dioro's
reaction in his Discord to the DMs being
leaked. Interesting. He's going with
DMs. I look good in all of these. I
could tell this was content as soon as
he started telling me how much he
respected me. Lol. Did he show why I was
mad at him or did he tell you why I was
mad? Lol. Is that all he showed? Seems
like kind of a half measure. No. Chud's
mad he's losing subs. Lol. To any
content creator watching, if you lose a
Dioro sub, that's that's basically a sub
gained if you think about it. Someone
clipped all the times I talked about him
and I think it was like 22 minutes
total. When has Nick Dioro ever gone up
against someone who genuinely disagreed
with him? Why hasn't he spoken to
Queman?
>> A lot of disagreements.
Any interest in talking to that guy?
Like this idea that I didn't even
mention him. I didn't even talk about
him much. Like why does he care? You're
not mentioning him to protect yourself.
Let's not get it twisted here. Weird. He
waited so long to talk about all of the
classic talking points. Haha. It's not a
safe space. Your friends put a bot in my
server and put my paid Discord on a
public website. I suppose the question
for Diorio is how long can you keep
doing this? How long can you be someone
else's slave? I mean, I'm sure the
money's great, but how long can you
pretend that you're satisfied with the
content that you're making? Would it
shock you if I said that Hassan [__]
>> Oh my god. Stop. Stop. It's like the
Epstein's Island [__] This is crazy.
This is an insane This is worse than I
thought. What is h I'm connecting the
dot, dude. Stop. Did you know Morgie
Morgan is actually friends with Assan
[__] who hates Jews and loves abusing
his animals? I hate Assan [__] and I
hate these people more. I hate these
people so much. They're like actually
[__] insane. They dude people will
put me next to these people because I
also criticize
>> because you are the same because you
make those same [__] [__]
statements, dude.
>> Assad [__]
>> Yeah. Yeah. You You're a part of that
ecosystem. You're a part of that
anti-Han.
>> You push the same [__] [__]
I've broken your principles in the same
ways.
Yeah. Yeah. You're the same. Yes.
ecosystem because let's look at your
content. Ethan Klein unloads on denims.
Assan Piker's ventriloquist dummy. Assan
[__] Assan [__] Like, need I explain
to you why you're so very clearly in the
ecosystem?
>> It's [__] insane.
>> He primarily
>> We need to drain the swamp, dude. I'm
sorry. I don't care if I lose some
[__] re uh reactionary viewer, bro.
>> Reactionary viewer. Drain the swamp. You
are the swamp. You are the Pegasus. You
are the Asben Gold Cliffs. You have
decided that this is the ecosystem you
want to be a part of. And you've done it
by being Ethan Klein's mouthpiece. Bro,
we need to [__] drain the swamp.
There is just too guys. There is too
much of this going on in the hating
Hassan [__] community. Holy [__] dude.
These people are actually they're every
bit as bad as he says they are. Yeah.
Yeah, this is why nobody can get held
accountable because Hassan [__] is bad.
>> Talking about anti-white racism.
>> I'm starting to get blackfilled a little
bit. I get why people hate EDHD stuff.
It has given so many people a voice who
are just like subhuman wretches.
>> What do you think we think of you, you
fat [__]
>> Just like literally piling on. I
understand why people are getting so
annoyed by it now.
>> What does that have to do?
>> I am awake and I can see these people. I
hate them too. At one point, Dioro had a
soul. He said what was on his mind. He
made video essays. He explained himself
and the beliefs that he held. He was not
someone guided by audience capture. But
in this clip, you can see that he is
starting to feel that burn. Is Nick
Dioro just another think before you
sleep? Is Nick Dioro just another
Pegasus? Yeah, man. Good luck with
whatever you're doing over there. I I
personally when I read that, I read it
in a way where he's he's clearly being
demeaning. Good luck with whatever
whatever you got going on over there
with your [__] 600 views, your your
thousand concurrent, okay? Whatever the
[__] you're doing over there. But you
know what's cool about Chudlo Logic is
he doesn't need to depend on anyone.
He's not leeching off of some bigger
YouTubers's audience. Those 1,000 people
that that 600 to 1,000 people that show
up for Chudlogic, those people are there
for him. The people that are showing up
for Nick Dioro, I mean, what 4,000
5,000? How many of those people are
there for Nick? How many of them are
there for just somebody that's going to
[__] talk Hassan? Somebody that is
friends with Ethan Klein. Nicholas Dioro
is the most successful streaming orbiter
I have ever seen. I just wonder how long
you can be someone's [__] Wow. Damn.
What a video. Great, great little recap.
I guess Nick's starting though, so let's
switch over. So guys, now we've got
Nick's actual response. So he had some
like little [__] like whiny response
last night where he didn't reset
anything,
but I guess he's going to respond more
substantively now. And um if it if it
drags on and he's just like ranting
about [__] nothing and making go slot
references, maybe we dip out and come
back cuz I can't be [__] wasting my
time with this tonight.
>> I wasn't sure if we were going to do
this segment. I went back and forth on
it for a while. I didn't really think I
needed to do one to be honest cuz most
people pretty much already agree with
me. Before we get started, I want to
establish a couple of ground rules. um
don't feel compelled to donate tonight
because uh there's no notifications and
because I'm, you know, trying to do a
show here and I'll be reading all
donations after tomorrow's live stream.
So donations are on back burner for
tonight. This is a single segment. No
introduction, no second segment. We're
just going to go through this from start
to finish and I'm going to give you
>> So dude, okay, he's like upset.
He's like actually upset.
So, I sort of didn't know what the vibe
was going to be here, but he is like
genuinely kind of upset about this
because
he's going he's not doing a proper
stream. He's felt compelled to go live
for this single segment to do a minimal
stream. He was saying his Discord, "Oh,
I'm not doing this. I'm not making money
off of it." And now he's instantly
gimping the amount of money he's going
to make. And he's preloading it with,
"Well, most people agree with me anyway.
So, you feel like some people don't.
You're upset that you feel like some
people don't.
Okay,
>> my side of the story. Now, I watched
Chudlo Logic's little crybaby response,
the two-hour version, and I commend DK
editing, because he worked really hard
to condense that [__] down to 40
minutes. You know how much random
[__] coping and seething at his own
chat that he had to remove to even make
it somewhat watchable. It's still not
very watchable, but it's better than the
version that I that I actually reviewed
for this segment because I went back to
the original one. Anyways,
>> it's like you can't do that. Oh, you get
mad at your chat all the time. Your
content sucks when you were begging him
up the whole time and he's been like
that the whole time.
Like literally two weeks ago it was, "Oh
no, I like Chad's content. I like Chad's
content." And you still showed up in his
chat. And now all of a sudden Chud's
content is totally unwatchable when the
whole time he's always spent half of his
stream screaming at chat.
Like it's just so blatantly
disingenuous. You're just like, you were
just doing this [__] woman thing where
when you fall out with someone, you
change your opinion of everything they
ever did.
You know, fortunately,
even when me and Nick were friends, I
told him that he made too many GOP
references and that I didn't watch his
streams. So, I have no no guilt about
saying that. hell
to even make it somewhat watchable. It's
still not very watchable, but it's
better than the version that I that I
actually reviewed for this segment
because I went back to the original one.
>> This is a game.
>> Anyways, Tread Logic upload this video
about me.
>> Anyways, no target coded.
>> Uh well, yeah, last night actually um I
think he expected me to respond to this
or not respond to this, but it was it
was interestingly interestingly timed or
whatever because I was about to go live.
So, this is the the the response to the
Chud claims from his stream segment. I'm
going to take you through it right now
because actually, I think you're all
aware of this. He released my DMs. Fair
play. Fine. I've released DMs before.
I'm not going to go and [__] go
postal and say, "Oh, it's super [__]
up that you're leaking DMs. The golden
rule, man." But what I am going to do is
explore these DMs because it was really
[__] stupid that he put them out.
>> Right. So, just to get started here,
let's review what Chud Logic has
released. And I'll get into why it's
significant periodically throughout the
little presentation I'm going to do with
you. We're going to come back to the
screenshot a lot.
>> So, you can see here on February 1st, I
wrote, "Yo,
>> like you were like this pressed over the
he said in DMs to Chud, I'm not debating
the friendship allegations, but you were
this pressed on stream over the
friendship allegations." And then on the
14th of Janu sorry, January 2nd, I'm I'm
numbering this wrong because he's
European. On January 2nd, I wrote, "Yo."
And on January 14th, I wrote, "Hey, I
just saw a clip of you saying that I
don't like you anymore, but you haven't
answered any DMs from me since
September. Lmao, I did try to keep coms
open." Now, the context to this will
become more apparent as we proceed, but
this is how it was presented in his
stream. Then Chudlo Logic says, and I
swear to God, he chose to release this
on his own for the brief moment while
we're looking at DMs. I'm going to cover
that because it's it's blocking the
stuff. Um, hey man. Yeah, I've had a lot
on honestly it's difficult to even like
the [__] dramatic reading is so
cringe,
dude.
What was chat saying?
>> On February 1st, I wrote yo. And then on
the 14th of Janu sorry, January 2nd, I'm
I'm numbering this wrong because he's
European. On January 2nd, I wrote yo.
And on January 14th,
>> I don't know if I'm mentally ached, but
the Destiny Orbiter coding and speaking
patterns are very strong by Oreo so far.
>> No, they are. He's got them bad. He does
have them bad.
It's just like the dramatic reading.
Here's the thing. I understand that's
what streamers do, but the dramatic
reading doesn't line up with the message
at all.
I wrote, "Hey, I just saw a clip of you
saying that I don't like you anymore,
but you haven't answered any DMs from me
since September. Lmao, I did try to keep
comms open." Now, the context to this
will become more apparent as we proceed,
but this is how it was presented in his
stream. Then, Chud Logic says, and I
swear to God, he chose to release this
on his own for the brief moment while
we're looking at DMs. I'm going to cover
that because it's it's blocking the
stuff. Um, hey man. Yeah, I've had a lot
on and honestly it's difficult to even
know what the deal is. We've gone our
separate ways in many ways and obviously
it does feel a bit [__] that no one
really likes me anymore from the
commentary community space. I do
probably have some issues with some of
your coverage, but I don't
>> This is just like it literally makes my
skin kind of cruel listening to him talk
like this.
Why does he have such a rapey energy? I
keep talking about EHD. And honestly,
I've appreciated the things that you've
done for me. So, I make these snarky
jabs from time to time just to signal to
you that I disagree, but I don't want to
blow up what little bridge we have left
by going full skitso mode attacking you.
I guess I feel estranged. Which I
thought was really weird because I said,
"Hey, Matt, you just went on stream and
told everybody that I don't like you
because you're friends with Queen and um
you've ghosted me since September, so
that's kind of odd. But thank you for
the random glaze, I guess, and you
feeling people sad about it. So I wrote
back, just to be perfectly transparent
with you, the conversation here soured
my perception of you. I have many
friends in the online ecosystem that I
disagree with or who make different
content than me. That was never my
issue. Despite this, I did attempt to
keep the bridge open regardless. So then
I didn't really respond to him. So he
gets like more and more desperate as I
don't respond to him. So it starts off
with him saying, "So yeah, I mean that
backs up my feeling of, you know, being
estranged. It's all good. I don't matter
or anything. Um, well, things change and
people do different things and at this
point I still haven't responded. And how
long was this? Was this like was this
like 10 minutes? Then he writes,
"Listen, man.
>> It's not even long enough for there to
be a break in those messages, dude. It
only breaks there. What do you mean?"
>> And uh, not everything has to be some
catastrophic breakdown. I know you're
used to that. I'm just like, "Yeah, man.
Good luck. Whatever you're doing over
there, good luck with whatever you're
doing over there. Fine. Cool. No
problem." The interesting thing about
how Chud leaked these
>> dude like Yeah. He's trying to make
amends with you and you're being [__]
Yes. DMs is because it was very apparent
to me while I was watching his stream
that he didn't really want me to. Well,
he didn't really want to rather
>> after that stream. And I've archived it
already. I've already archived it.
>> His chat like bullied him into leaking
these DMs, which is I It's It's really
awkward.
>> Wait, but dude, literally that straight
up contradicts what Nick was saying when
he was watching the stream in Discord.
Nick is saying, "I knew this was going
to be content the moment he said he
respected me in those DMs."
That's what he was saying in his Discord
when this was being aired. I knew he was
going to leak this. I knew this was
going to be content for him the moment
he said he respects me in those DMs
and now it's He didn't even want to leak
these DMs. He didn't even want to do
this.
>> I don't know why people are acting like
I've got to [__] archive everything.
It's fine.
>> At one point he says, "My word is my
bond." Which again, I don't care if
you're leaking my DMs, but I don't know
why you leak DMs where I look normal.
>> Why is everyone freaking out? Relax,
relax, relax, bro. [laughter] Relax.
Why do people want to see the DM so
much?
>> Why do they want to see the DM so much?
Why do we want to see the DM, dude?
Yeah. Look, look, dude. Look at his
[laughter]
Look at the Chod live stream VOD
playlist for Nick. He watches every
stream. Chad's unwatchable. I got He
watches every stream. He watches it to
the end. He watches He still watches
every stream to completion.
How does DK even cut this [__] down?
>> You watch every [__] stream, dude.
You literally watched every single one
from beginning to end.
>> Keep in mind, he's got these archived.
That's why my new profile picture is in
them.
>> I don't understand, dude.
It's not that [__] deep, bro. It's
not [laughter] that [__] deep, bro.
But yes, it felt very much.
It felt very much like
>> like you want to call this guy a chat
slave, you can because just watch,
>> you know.
Like this is going to be the constant
flow with Nick. It's that I'm going to
make some comment on stream. Okay. It's
I'm going to make some comment on stream
and he's going to come angrily to me
privately with
>> put a pin in that one as well.
>> Have a private conversation, resolve it,
but nothing's really resolved and
there's still this underlying tension.
>> Apparently, I run to him every time he
says something about me on stream and
then we resolve it privately.
>> And those messages were the first time
that I realized he'd had this problem
with me about this and how it happened
after.
>> So, this narrative is very interesting.
I do want to establish this early.
Chudlogic wants you, the viewer, to
believe that he knew he was estranged
for six consecutive months and knew
something was wrong, but he was entirely
caught off guard when I told him that
there was something wrong. How can those
two things both be true?
So, is that really what he's saying?
>> And then we resolve it. I I think he's
saying that you didn't outright say it,
that you weren't being forthcoming, that
you were sort of being conflict avoidant
and not actually saying, "Oh, this is
such an issue that we can't hang out
anymore." And so then you you you leave
it. You leave it and then eventually it
bubbles up.
Is that not what he's saying? Very much
like
>> like you want to call this guy a chat
slave, you can because just watch.
>> You know,
like this is going to be the constant
flow with Nick. It's that I'm gonna make
some comment on stream. Okay. It's that
I'm gonna make some comment on stream
and he's gonna come angrily to me
privately with
>> Put a pin in that one as well.
>> Have a private conversation, resolve it,
but nothing's really resolved and
there's still this underlying tension.
>> Apparently, I run to him every time he
says something about me on stream and
then we resolve it privately.
>> And those messages were the first time
that I realized he'd had this problem
with me about this and how it happened
afterwards.
>> So, this narrative is very interesting.
I do want to establish this early.
Chudlogic wants you, the viewer, to
believe that he knew he was estranged
for six consecutive months and knew
something was wrong, but he was entirely
caught off guard when I told him that
there was something wrong. How can those
two things both be true
>> for months? For [__] months, dude.
>> So, yes, I was aranged. I was aranged.
None of the other commentary cards like
me anymore. And Nicholas had this issue
with me for months that he hadn't really
expressed and just hadn't really kind of
been honest about.
Now again, I hadn't expressed these
issues. I hadn't been honest about these
issues. I thought you ghosted me since
se Well, we'll get there. I'm getting
ahead of myself. We'll get there. I'm
sorry. So, yeah, it was just this kind
of unending underlying tension.
That was just kind of like
unresolved.
Wonder why.
>> Yeah. Like feels pretty clear what he's
saying there. No, I I don't think
>> he felt what you know. I don't know. I
don't know because I didn't want to talk
privately or something. I said I'd
wanted to talk privately and never
followed it up with him about this clip
about
>> Wait, how could Hold on. So, I didn't
tell you there was anything wrong, but
you offered a conversation with me and
you never followed up on it. And you
were surprised that I was not happy with
you for a while about Oh, that's that's
that's a [__] weird one, too. What is
that about?
>> [__] that happened around it.
>> That's a weird admission.
>> I'm malicious.
>> At what point where does he say at what
point does he say, "Oh, there was never
any indication of an issue up until
right now." Where did he ever say that?
Where did he ever say that? He's very
clear there was indications of an issue
beforehand.
What do you mean?
>> What do you What do you mean, bro? What
do you mean?
What do you mean? What is malicious
here? me responding to Nicholas waiting
till I go on holiday to say a bunch of
crazy [__] about me to make out like I'm
like I'm an I'm Alex type beggar and
then I'm responding to it or me saying
well hey here's a bit of a background of
how this came to be how is that
malicious bro
>> you got to keep up the actual topic here
stop fighting with the chat I'm trying
to get to a point
>> I am responding dude this idea that I am
some [__] snake this idea
>> I got to I got to fast forward through
the coping can we get to the point where
he starts showing the DMs it's got to be
there okay here we go here we go okay
the [__] DMs dude there's no need to
just bro my word is my bond Okay. My
word is my bond. You guys just want to
see DMs. You don't need to see them,
bro.
>> Why does Chud Logic not want to show his
DMs with me?
>> You don't need to see
>> Why Why would he not want to show his
This is so weird.
>> See them?
If he didn't want to show them, he could
have just not shown them.
Only a total [__] would read this that
way.
Only someone who is legitimately
[__] would read this as Ch like or
Ch just totally does not want to show
them. But Chad's just making him.
He wants to leak the DMs for the
content. He's playing like he doesn't.
>> We saw them. They were
>> Well, I mean, you know, there there's
probably some reservation, but I don't
want to I don't want to leak DMs. I'll
put a bit of resistance,
but you know, he's he's going to leak
your DMs. It's obvious he's going to
leak with DMs.
really damning. He didn't want to show
them. Better question is, when you were
in Vietnam and I was supposedly plotting
against you, why didn't I redact them?
Unless I wanted you to have them.
>> Nicholas is going to show them.
>> It's so cringe, man. It's so cringe. I
can't do the lean in. I can't. My
[__] skin crawls, dude. It's
genuinely so [__] fatty. So cringy.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay, fine. I'll show it. [__] it. [__]
it. I'll show it. [__] you, Nicholas
Doro.
>> So, there he is. Chud gets bullied into
showing my DMs. And those are the ones
we just saw here. Now, I did notice that
eagle-eyed viewers pointed out that the
messages that Nick said ruined his
perception of Chud were actually not one
of the ones that were included in the
leak. And until it's released, Chud's
acting like Tom's accusers selectively
releasing DMs. And that would be [__]
damning if that if Chud selectively
released DMs. Well, we can see that we
haven't had the whole week. We can see
that. That's very clear. That's very
clear. Now, the real defining factor
here isn't are there other DMs that
could be leaked. It's are there other
DMs that drastically change our
impression of this situation. Are there
more DMs that come out to show actually
Nick has a really legitimate reason to
be upset at Chud that is totally
disconnected from any jokes about
blocking or sucking Ethan Klein's [__]
or whatever the [__] And you know guys,
that could be the case. It could be the
case that Nick has a legitimate reason
to dislike Chud. So let's hear him out.
Let's hear him out. I'm open. I'm open.
>> That would be pretty [__] bad. Now,
Corn Toasty did say, "To be fair, the
way it's worded, sounds like this
conversation reference might have been
in a Discord call and not text
messages." So, even though this is all a
terrible look for Chud, there might not
be any other relevant texts, which is a
good point. That is a possibility
because he's referencing something here,
but there's no there's no way that like
this message that's highlighted in
yellow is publicly available, like not
publicly available, but like accessible
to Chudlogic that he could have shown
you the actual context for.
So, that's what we're going to be going
through tonight because it absolutely
[__] was there. He just didn't want
you to see it. So, ladies and gentlemen,
>> idiot, whatever. The main thing that I
want to establish with you for the
context that you're about to see is my
understanding
>> is literally dude and we are immediately
pulling up.
You suck Ethan Klein's [__] Nicholas
Yorio. I'm talking to you. We're
literally okay. Look, I'm reserving
judgment. I'm reserving judgment. Okay.
Maybe there is something that spins off
of this that's really bad. Okay.
>> Bud logic back in the day. And you must
have seen these rants because I remember
them. And this is one example I'm going
to show you from a relevant video.
Chudlogic would constantly fight with
his audience because he felt like we
were being pit against each other and he
wanted to maintain our friendship.
>> Chud Logic lives on an island. They
always his little audience members go
and chase away every single person he's
friendly with.
>> Oh my god. It's Dude, literally
listening to a Tommy C stream now, dude.
It's actually the little [__] talking
they've done the whole time.
>> You're you're on an island. You can't do
anything without us.
>> Okay, dude. They want him to stay on his
own little own little island, make
content by himself, and that's just the
reality of of what Chudlo Logic's
content.
>> Not what they want at all. It's not what
they want at all. It's just that they
want the [__] losers that come on to
be held to account when they're trying
to, you know, [__] a bit. That's
obviously what the issue is. When you go
on and you're bullshitting, they want
you pressed and you're mad about that.
Ernie is and will ever forever be as
long as he remains audience captured the
way that he is. So Chudlo Logic would go
on these rants trying to like reel his
audience in because he did not want
conflict with me.
>> I will moderate the Homent.
>> You can't stop me, Chudlo Logic. I will
be a Reddit moderator.
>> Thank you for the $5. Thank you against
Assan.
>> Anything that goes against Assam worthy
of support.
>> You became a member. The cheese wheel
celebrates 10 months of membership. Go
off chy buddy. FK regarded wars and
politics over dirt and religion.
>> Thank you Cheese Wheel for the
membership.
So, this is the clip.
>> No, I'm not bringing up Nicholas Dory
stream. I'm not making it about anyone
individual, okay? I don't [__] care
about your gay camera. This is also
really Do you know what? You know what?
Whilst we're here, I'll also say this as
well. I'm so [__] sick of you utter
cretins desperately trying to [__]
throw a wedge between me and the Oreo
because he's [__] sucking Ethan Klein at
the moment. Okay, I [__] have got my
issues with it, but you guys are so
[__] You're like raping my brain with
this [__]
>> People in his chat are raping his brain
to try to get us to fight each other and
he doesn't like that.
>> [__] unbelievable, dude. If you got
Yeah, that that means he's like totally
brainwashed. Yeah, that's what he's
saying.
>> Got a problem with what N is saying.
That's between you and Nicholas. If
you've got a problem with something that
Creman is saying, that is between you
and Creman. I'm talking broadly about
the issues that exist that I've noticed
and you are trying to press laser focus.
>> All right. So, this is my major issue
with Tre Logic. I was under the
assumption that he wasn't lying, that he
actually didn't want us to fight each
other, that he actually didn't like how
his audience was trying to pit us
against each other, and he he actually
felt like he was kind of in a bad way.
That was my understanding, and that was
clearly my bad. So, now I'm going to
show you the message where I ran to him
crying and oh my god, I it doesn't
appear that I've done that. Boom. What
happened? Wait, this can't be the start
of the conversation. I was told that
Nick was in tears. What the [__] Why is
this a Reddit post from H3 Snark making
a joke that they referred to Chud Logic
as one of the biggest sweepers of Ethan
Klein? What the [__] I thought I
thought I was supposed to be an
emotional crybaby that I was running to
Chud Logic. Oh, wait. What is this? Then
he starts sucking my dick.
>> Okay, I'm not going to lie. the fact
you're sending him like some H3 snark
post that you're obviously seething over
with this clip of him shitalking you.
>> Dude, I was absolutely raging yesterday.
I hope I didn't cause you any grief.
Well, that's not exactly how he
presented that in the live show, is it?
>> Yeah, that that's like
reasonable. What's the problem with
this? So, you seem to be raising this
clip with him. He's saying, "Hope it
didn't cause you any grief." Is that how
he presented this in a live show where
he's just because you're sending a post
from like a hater subreddit? This would
be like sending a Kiwi Farms post or
something, right?
And being like, "Oh, look at this. It's
a clip of them shit-talking you." But
yeah, it kind of seems like maybe you're
saying
you're bothered, you know? That's kind
of how this comes across. Otherwise, why
else are you looking at this [__]
hater so it's ceing?
>> Just like, "Dude, I was I was absolutely
raging yesterday. I I hope I didn't
cause you any grief.
>> Yeah. So, this was the thread. I just
thought it was funny. It was the video,
so it's a halftruth, I guess. Um, but
yeah, leftovers H3 clip Chud's rants
where he's like, "Fuck you, Nickorio."
And they called him Ethan Klein.
>> Yeah. What kind of responses you want to
this? Which I thought was funny.
>> So, from there,
>> wait,
no, don't do your narrative. You've
already You've just shown some DMs
there. We'll skip the narrative. Thank
you very much. We'll go straight to that
next page of DMs.
Where's that? I know. I just really
don't understand sto [laughter]
guys. I didn't run to him crying. I just
sent him the hate subreddit and then
when he responded, I immediately started
crying. [laughter]
Dude, you can't make it up.
[snorts]
I know. I just don't really understand
stoking the flames and taking shots
against my character if you're annoyed
people are baiting and trying to make us
argue. That seems fairly
counterproductive.
Some of the stuff you talked about is
stuff I've complained about like people
annoyingly agreeing with Nox. So, I
don't know. Just feels like I came in
telephone with a lot of assumptions
being made. Yeah, I understand. Just
feel totally raped at the moment.
Obviously have some issues/
disagreements, etc., but can't
reasonably state them without causing
some stupid beef. Can't react to your
exact takes without causing drama. Seems
that onream discussion would be more
raped and more drama, etc. So it's
obvious what he's saying here. He's
saying
so Chud is basically saying Chud is
looking for room to disagree in that
message. That is looking for room to
disagree. That is saying I disagree with
you. I've got problems with some of the
things I've seen you say, but I know if
I talk about at length, you're going to
cry.
And you're also going to cry if I ask
you to talk about on stream, aren't you?
You're also going to cry if you know we
want to debate it on stream. I can tell
you for a fact if I was, you know,
talking to Ch DMs about disagreeing and
there would never be a message like this
where it's like, oh well, having an
onream discussion be a problem. Having a
onreen that would never be there. That
would never be there. So I have no
reason to believe this is here because
Chud is worried about,
you know, potentially looking bad on a
stream. And then he was more than happy
to go, you know, having already taken
[__] for his ice take,
he was happy to go and debate peace.
So there's no reason for me to believe
that messages like this about where he's
trying to find room to disagree are
there because he's worried about,
you know, what his reaction to the drama
is going to be. No, he's worried about
Nick's reaction to the drama,
obviously.
So from there,
>> okay,
>> this is
where are we? Oh, I hit the wrong one.
Sorry. So from there I because Chud
Logic has now brought it up. I gave him
the issue that I had with his segment.
So he goes, "Haha, dude, we're
absolutely raging yesterday. I hope
>> dude, you sent him a [__] post from a
hate sovereign. It's obvious you were
bringing it up because you're kind of
like in a in some kind of way about you.
You're like sitting there ruminating
looking at hate sovereign. It's obvious,
dude. Not everyone is as [__]
autistic as Boax or whoever else you've
been used to having these conversations
with. Dude,
>> I didn't cause you any grief. And I
said, I know. I just really don't
understand you stoking the flames and
taking shots at my character if you're
annoyed that people are baiting and
trying to make us argue. That seems
fairly counterproductive, but some of
the stuff that you've talked about is
stuff that I've complained about. He is,
dude. He is simultaneously
annoyed at people trying to bait an
argument that will destroy the
friendship
and annoyed about his perceived lack of
room in the friendship to say what he
thinks because it's obvious you'll cut
him off if he does because you've done
it before.
>> Two, like people annoyingly agreeing
with Noxaku. So, I don't know. It just
feels like a weird game of telephone
where a lot of assumptions were being
made. I think this is a reasonable thing
to ask somebody who is publicly facing
and privately facing telling people that
they do not like when people are trying
to
>> obviously coddling him so hard.
>> A big old a bear hug even.
>> Thank you for the $5. Thank you
>> each other. It seems like a weird thing
to go on a lengthy rant about it if this
is something that you do not want
something that is very interesting.
>> Reserve judgment. Reserve judgment.
Maybe something terrible is said. Also,
not all the comments are about you. It
was about everyone in an amorphous blob.
One minute.
Wait, how? Where are we here? Let's run
this back.
>> Whatever.
>> A main thing that I That's what we're
going to be going through.
>> Okay, so we haven't gotten to the
message apparently made Nick upset yet.
>> People are baiting and trying to
annoying and privately facing telling
people that they do not like when people
are trying to pit us against each other.
It seems like a weird thing to go on a
lengthy rant about it. If this is
something that you do not want, then
>> he's saying he hates the people pitting
him against you, but he also has
disagreements your coverage and hates
the lack of room. So he does he goes on
a rant of people trying to force it and
then also lays out some of his
frustration. How is that not reasonable?
Please, someone, I'm I'm open. How is
that not totally reasonable? This is
clearly Nick trying to make sure that he
shuts up. That's obviously what's being
said here. I know. I just don't really
understand stoking the flames, taking
shots on my character. If you're annoyed
people, why don't you just shut up? Why
don't you just stop? Why don't you just
stop talking about me?
Shlogic wrote something that is very
interesting. He said, "Yeah, I
understand. I just feel totally raped at
the moment. I obviously have some issues
and disagreements, but I can't
reasonably state them without causing
some stupid beef." Wait, what do you
mean stupid beef? I thought this was
Nicholas, where are you? Why are you not
on my stream? What? What? Wait, what do
you mean stupid beef? I thought this was
I thought this was Kino important
content. And then he says, "I can't."
>> Yeah, the stupid beef is the fallout in
the friendship, dude. The disagreement
doesn't have to be a massive fallout,
but he's referring to the idea of
falling out with you as the stupid beef
because there's there's sort of like a
you know, I think I kind of operate this
way. T operates this way and the lines
are blurred here. It's not perfect, but
there's sort of like a a difference
between in the- moment content and the
disagreements you're having in the
content in your broader, you know, uh uh
relationship to these people. It's like
that you can you can have the content
disagreement and that's fine and good,
but you don't want this stupid personal
[__] getting in the way where you where
there's a bunch of bad feelings that
cause you to not want to talk to each
other again, right? That that's like
obviously what's happening here.
I
I tr this is going to work on his some
of his audience. At least some of them.
At least some of them. React to your
exact takes without causing drama. I I
thought wasn't the commentary community
on Auggie stream founded by the guys in
the trenches fighting every little
talking point. I'm so confused. Tudlogic
in public wants you to believe, right,
that he's been trying. He's been edging.
He wanted to talk about this for months.
But Todd Logic in my DMs is a cowering
little [__] who's SAYING, "OH, I DON'T
WANT ANY I DON'T WANT NO drama with you,
Nick Orio. I can't even do this without
causing any beef. I don't want any
drama." Right? Then
>> what does he think is being said there?
Does he truly think by he doesn't want
any drama? He means I don't want to
fight with you in public. No, he's
saying he doesn't want a personal
fallout. He says, "Seems like an onreen
discussion would have been what do you
mean?"
>> or raped and more drama.
>> That's an a particularly interesting
point for me because Chud logic is
telling me for the first time that he
has no interest in a debate with me
unprompted.
That's not what he's saying. That is
clearly not what is being said there.
He's not saying no interest. Seems that
on stream discussion would be more rape
and more drama, etc. He's raising the
idea. That's almost a prompt for you to
say, "No, that could work.
But he knows you don't want to. That's
why he's not pressing it immediately.
That's why he's not going for it. That
seems so clear. Maybe there's other
messages that change my impression here.
That seems so clear to me in this
message. Why else bring it up? Why else
bring it up? [laughter]
>> HE DIDN'T WANT TO CHAT with me, dude.
I'm sorry if you're
>> Nick. Never Nick is the one that has
issues having these conversations. Ch is
more than happy to have conversations
with anyone about this [__]
That's proven out. Nick is clearly the
one who will not have conversations
about [__] That's clear.
How can you even try to spin this any
other way?
You're an avid Chudlo Logic fan and
you're one of the guys that hate me. Uh,
and you think that he's been fighting
for you privately behind the scenes, but
actually Chud's a huge [__] and he
didn't want any beef with me for the
longest time. Uh, and he this is how he
talked to me in DMs and it doesn't sound
like the way he talked to you on stream.
Isn't that weird? Isn't that weird? So
they tried logic.
>> Literally everyone knows this is what
he's like. What do you mean?
>> I thank you for the 20 gifted
memberships. That's insanely generous of
you. Thank you so much, dude. Literally
everyone I don't think. Guys, put one in
chat if this is exactly what you expect
from Chud DMs. two in chat if this has
completely shattered your image of Chud
as some hyper combative guy at all times
with his with his friends. Yeah, it's
it's looking like a lot of ones. Solid
ones. I'm assuming there's a lot of
crossover with Chud here for obvious
reasons. So, also not all the comments
were about you. It was about everybody
and sort of an amorphous blob. So Chad
Logic told me that he's been totally
feeling raped recently and he can't talk
about any of this stuff without his
audience that it captured him getting on
his ass and annoying the [__] out of
them because he's perpetually one guy by
a chat full of piranhas that he can't do
anything about and he's terrified of
them. So I thought this is like going to
be it, you know, cuz
>> Ch is very consiliatory and nice in DMs
and will fight on stream.
That's just the case cuz why would you
spend your time off the clock getting
into fights? You know, you want to
maintain your relationships, be chill
with people, and have the fights in the
content where you're getting paid, where
you're both doing something for your
careers, you know.
Thank you for the $20, Jimly. The grand
narrative of Chud thinking he was ex
friend group and nickname Chud Ghost is
uh until it fell apart. Most
embarrassing way two grown men can end.
Very, very gay. Very true. This is like
a really awkward scenario that's
happening here because it sounds like
he's telling everybody publicly one
thing and he's telling me something. Uh,
but also maybe there is some other
position here that I'm not
understanding. This is kind of weird.
Maybe we just move on from here and
every So then he uploads this segment
immediately the same day and they
[__] put it out as fast as possible.
Is it the same day? What is this? Um, is
it the 29th? Where's the next day? No,
it's the same day. So he rushes his
segment out called the state of the
commentary community and it opens like
this where he's screaming and crying
about how Auggie did like a fun um IRL
stream and about how I am inclined. It's
like, oh, why would you even be mad
about that, bro?
>> The the RFC mania thing was funny. It
was fun. Um, do you think or is
screaming? No. I think Orie is kind of
indifferent as to whether Nick does a
bunch of [__] [__] Thank you for
$5. Thank you.
>> That's just banter, mate. It's just
banter. Banter for Chud Logic is he's
mad at his chat who's attacking him, so
he takes it out on his friends. That's
what banter means to Chud Logic. These
little jabs and things, they're to
satiate the blood lust in his chat. He's
terrified of you.
>> Doing tricks for treats, like shaving
their head. It's pathetic and wretched.
Like, it started off and I could
understand it.
>> He's totally raped, guys. He doesn't
want to deal with this at all. Then the
video from DK comes out. They're like,
"Holy [__] this treat like a big
[music] [__] freak."
>> It's obvious projection. It's just
obvious projection.
Chun is blatantly
not [__] terrified of his chat or
terrified of
spicy or whatever the [__] that is.
Clearly, you are concerned about that.
And so you were saying,
>> you think is concerned screaming as Nick
as his phone on do not disturb.
>> Thank you for the $5 $5. Thank you. Yep,
that's obviously projection. That is
Nick is worried about that. So, he
assumes Chud must be and that's why this
is happening. People's chats are a
reflection of the stream and the
streamer. You know, the
the reason Chud seems to align with his
chat a lot is because there are things
that obviously float. There are a bunch
of retards that float around Chud's
stream that don't quite get it that have
different opinions, you know, and
obviously it's not everyone doesn't
agree on everything,
but you know what I mean, right? There's
sort of like this there's right-wing and
commentary types
that obviously don't
quite come at it from the same place a
lot of other people do that have been in
Ch's community for a long time and TH
himself, but the core sort of, you know,
vibe of the community
obviously
comes from the way Chud's been,
right? That's it's it is a reflection.
is you you you attract a certain type of
people by being a certain way. So this
idea the idea that you you
really you know it is a little bit
chicken and egg
but the idea that you're going oh he's
just ter he's terrified of his chat
that's you projecting that's you
projecting you are terrified of your
chat first of all you're terrified of
your own chat why you have to pretend to
either understand or not understand Zog
depending on what's happening on the
stream that day and have to lie about
whether you understand antiic dog
whistles or not and have to lie about
rape reviews and what happened in rape
review because you're worried about your
new wine mom audience. And worse than
that, you're terrified of Chud's chat.
You're terrified of Chud's chat and
Chud's Discord very blatantly
freak. You're a total freak [__]
shaving your head for [music] cash and
you're trying to act like it's normal.
No, it's not normal. Unless you're
willing to do the 20th stream sucking
off Ethan Clyde. Yes, I'm talking about
you, Nicholas. Okay, dude. I saw some
Stardust clip, right? and Froggen, the
stupid fat wench. I don't [__] like
Frogan, right? But she says something
about the ADL negative.
So, he puts out the segment, does the
I'm calling you out, Nick Dioro bit. So,
at this point, I'm really confused cuz
this makes no [__] sense to me that
he would say this and then upload the
segment. So, I go, hm, call me crazy,
but I think it's probably not you being
frustrated that people keep talking
about it or trying to get us to fight
each other considering that you are now
playing into it. I again, I think this
is an entirely reasonable position for
me to have based off the positions that
Chudlock Chudlo Logic has shared. This
is not, "Oh no, you're messing up my
money. Oh no, you're attacking me over
Ethan Klein." you're kind of a [__]
hypocrite, dude. This kind of sucks. So
then I start responding to him. This is
hours later after the video comes out.
And I go, "Right." And so he goes, "All
the comments, not all the comments were
about you. He's been doing this for
quite a while. He's extremely vague on
purp."
>> So literally now he's he's showing that
despite him not saying there was a big
problem. So
all he says in those DMs is,
"I don't understand stoking the flames,
taking shots of my character for
annoying the people of baiting and
trying to make us argue." And all he's
saying is that the reason why he doesn't
want people to make them argue is
because he knows you will blow up. So
then DK cuts this video
>> considering that you are now playing
into it again.
>> And obviously that's not to defuse
responsibility. It's Chud's channel.
This is Chud's video that Chad blew up
as far as uh you know responsibility
goes.
>> And I think this is an entirely
reasonable position for me to have based
off the positions that Chud Chud logic
has shared. This is not oh no you're
messing up my money. Oh no you're
attacking me over Ethan Klein. you're
kind of a [__] hypocrite, dude. This
kind of sucks. So then I start
responding to him. This is hours later
after the video comes out and I go,
"Right." And so
>> Nick thought he would get Venezuela, but
instead got Vietnam and now he's running
scared BC. He's actually getting push
back BC. He had nothing on Sh.
>> Thank you for the $5. Thank you.
>> He goes, "All the comments, not all the
comments were about you. He's been doing
this for quite a while. He's extremely
vague on purpose so he can satiate his
audience, but also take no
accountability for me." Um, also not all
the comments were about you. it was
about everyone in sort of an amorphous
blob, right? But that just means they're
going to assume it's all about me
because you opened with yes, I'm calling
you out, Nick Dioro, and then you said
that later. It's annoying that when I
get stupid comments about EHD is too
boring. I and my chat can attest to
this. Send them to Chudlogic and say,
"Hey, man. Look, if you don't like what
I'm covering, you can go check out what
Chud's doing. He's covering all this
different stuff." And that's totally
cool. I have no problem with that if
you're kind of bored over here. But when
Chudlo Logic,
>> dude, look, even here,
he's bullshitting and conflating.
The issue isn't that you cover Ethan,
[__] The issue is that you are a
dishonest [__] rat. That's the issue.
[__] idiot. Just try to conflate the
issues. People say they're bored about
with it. I told them to go, "What you?"
It's not about where they're bored with
it. [__] has people go, "hm, can you
cover the new Idubbbz thing?" He just
calls me a [__] compromised dick
sucker and [__] attacks my character.
So, I don't know why he does that, but
whatever. Cool. Fine. But why is it my
fault that people want you to watch?
>> I was nice to you. Why are you voicing
disagreements with me? Why are you
voicing disagreements and talking [__]
like a content creator? Please give me a
[__] break. The most popular topic at
the time. This just kind of sucks. I
don't know. It's kind of a weird [__]
thing to say. So then Chud Logic starts
going in my opinion kind of postal.
Yeah, obviously I have some
disagreements with the way things
>> Nick's performance reminds me of a drag
queen.
>> Thank you for the $5. Yeah, obviously I
have some disagreements for the way some
things have been discussed recently.
It's awkward because there's pressure to
have this big blowout drama/
disagreement which I don't really see
the value in. And obviously people s
around for any sort of disagreements
capitalize on for their own content
particularly from the side.
So what's the problem here
have been discussed recently. It's
awkward because there is this pressure
to have this big blowout drama
disagreement which I don't really see
the value in.
Hm.
It's almost like I had a completely
different understanding of who Chudlo
Logic was in comparison to the average
viewer who consumes his
>> Yeah, he said he's clearly saying he
doesn't want to end the [__]
relationship over it. Dude,
all you have to say here is, "Dude, this
agreement doesn't have to be ended
relationship. I should tash it out."
That's clearly what he's pressing for.
Am I Am I crazy? Am I reading this in a
totally crazy way? He wants to
voice the disagreements.
He said now multiple times. I have these
disagreements. It's awkward cuz we're
going to it's going to end the
relationship if we start talking about
it. I fear he said that multiple times
now and Nick is not going, "Sure, let's
talk about it."
So, it seems like Nick wants him to not
talk about it. Different understanding
of who Chud Logic was in comparison to
the average viewer who consumes his live
stream. I was blown away when I watched
some of the things that he would say on
stream because these are the things that
he would say to me. So he said it's
awkward because there's pressure to have
this big blowout drama disagreement
which I don't see.
>> Unfortunately Nick Nick does just
unfortunately sound like a rapist in the
in the manner of speech he has a lot of
time.
>> And obviously people are sniffing around
for any sort of disagreement to
capitalize on it for their own content
and Destiny and him had their little
falling out. Jud reached out and asked
me and to do commentary collabs with
him. That's like another that's like
another thing. So, the reason why you
constantly keep seeing Chudlo Logic say
things like, "I appreciate what you've
done for me," is because he's making
reference to that. That's what he's
making reference to. So, I say, "I don't
think that uh I don't think you've
really seen my positions outside of
clips that people who are farming have
sent you, but I would walk that back if
you've really watched me." And then
Chudlogic says, "Obviously, I appreciate
that. I appreciate what you have done
for me, and I consider you a friend. We
have had disagreements and hashed them
out before, and it's fine. I mean, I was
talking a bit of [__] and I haven't even
seen all your coverage, but you're
extremely favorable to Ethan to a fault.
No. So, at this moment, I realize, oh,
[__] This guy just doesn't watch me.
This guy doesn't watch anything that
this guy literally does not watch my
Whoa. Yeah, there's no way you could
possibly think that if you watch Nick
because it's not like Nick has
repeatedly swept for Ethan Klein
blatantly lying about Denim's chat and
the CPS thing. It's not like Nick has
completely switched up his principles on
copyright, defending the snark DMCAs,
defending the uh lawsuits against uh
denims despite the fact that it doesn't
actually fulfill the criteria that you
would usually support one on. Uh
supporting uh the use of de well not
supporting but not necessarily
criticizing, not condemning, just saying
it's a bad idea the inclusion of Dan
Saltman and the listing of Dan Saltman
despite the fact that he used to [__]
cry about Brit Bong being used by Ethan
Klein. Yeah, we could go down the list.
We really could keep going down the
list. No one could have ever watched a
Nick and have legitimate criticisms to
say he is sucking Ethan Klein's dick to
the point where it makes him totally
dishonest.
>> Uh, and you don't have to to be my
friend. You don't have to watch my
streams or watch my videos. Now, I was
very active in his chat and I was
[clears throat] I enjoyed his show a lot
and I thought he was a really
respectable guy, but at this point I
realized, oh, he just doesn't watch my
show, right? So then he goes, "Also,
that title and thumbnail is very tame.
No one's getting called the pedto." So I
guess at this point I got off better
than Lix. Lick's Lick's [laughter] got
it worse than me. So, this one is
basically inconsequential. This is me
trying to just establish talking points
to see what the problem is. I'll go
through it just for the sake of showing
all the DMs, but it's not really
relevant. I agree with you on Nucks. I
support the no legal threat on the basis
that he's defameing people maliciously
in the past. Ch logic. But I've also
said that Ethan should probably leave it
at a threat and I'd be open to seeing
what gets filed if ever it didn't. And
reassessing, I think the Nazi sword was
on purpose, but it was safe edgy, not
their secret KKK attackers. It was done
for safe edgy own. When they correct him
that it's in regards to the ban, this is
a random Hassan [__] ban from six
months ago. Not really relevant here.
Um, I said that you probably shouldn't
be banned otherwise I literally don't
know what other topics we even agree on.
So that was me kind of uh just
establishing talking points. But we rip
it back. We go back to the actual
discussion. So then he goes also the
title and thumbnail is very tame. No
one's getting called a pedto. So I then
rip the conversation back to the topic
at hand and say the confusion is you
seem frustrated.
>> I said like once in a while that I
disagree with a clip of a song. I I
disagree with the way a clip was a way a
song clip was clipped. I said it was out
of context one time. Guys, my coverage
is perfect.
Please keep eating
>> about the drama baiting and this seems
like another escalation that will extend
it which I think again warranted
question. Chudlogic says, "Oh, okay. I
mean, I said to DK to take it easy on
the title and thumbnail, mainly because
I'm probably going to lose subs over."
Remember when Chudlo Logic went live
yesterday and said, "GUYS, I LOSE SUBS
ALL THE TIME. NONE OF THIS MATTERS TO
ME." WELL, AGAIN, in private, he
actually is worried about losing those
subscribers. That was something that
mattered to him. Now, as time
progressed, I started to realize that
Chudlogic probably didn't even like me.
He
>> Yes. He's saying,
"Yes, he's saying to his editor,
go easy on that because we're probably
going to lose subs over it anyway."
He's not changing his decision so much
that he won't cover it or won't say it
or won't post it.
But he's saying, "Hey, editor whose job
it is to optimize my YouTube channel,
can you optimize this so that this
doesn't tank us quite so bad?"
I think that's totally reasonable.
That's literally that's better than 90%
of YouTubers. Most YouTubers simply
won't say the thing if they're going to
lose subs over it, you know,
like that is that is way more willing to
brave the loss in numbers. And this is
Nick who gets on stream every other week
and he's like, um, people gave me push
back for my take, but I checked the
video and it's got a 94% like ratio.
He was just probably worried that I was
going to pull out and take the rest of
my viewers with me, which is what
happened. That is what I did. So that he
just lied about that as well. But yeah,
I mean, there isn't much going on worthy
of a segment, so I'm just trying to
carve something out. What the [__] does
that mean? Wait, [laughter]
so wait, you're telling me you you're
telling me that you were bored on a
random [__] like Tuesday afternoon
and you just snaked me and you just told
me in plain English that that's what you
>> He's saying they didn't have a good
segment to post. could say he's
corpulant. G. This is because this
fellow is quite overweight. I think
using this as an insult would be funny.
>> Thank you for the $5.
It snaking you by having a meltdown on
stream that he knows is going to lose
him subscribers and he posts it just cuz
well there's nothing else to post that
day. And that's snaking Nick. Apparently
this is like totally reasonable. This is
exactly the thing man. You can't be
friends with Nick as another content
creator because he just doesn't want you
to do your [__] job.
He doesn't want you to do your [__]
job.
The moment the moment there's a piece of
drama that's worth posting that involves
Nick or could you there could be a
couple people say, "Oh, Nick's kind of
gay actually." Off the back of it, it's
like, "Why'd you do that? Why'd you do
that to me?"
>> He did. I didn't have any content, so I
just called you a fraud. How the [__]
was that?
>> No, he's saying that's why they posted
the segment. You [__] [__] Not
much going on that's worthy of a
segment. They're just trying to carve
something out as in carve something out
of the VOD. I supposed to interpret
this. I'm just curious how the [__] was
I supposed to interpret this message
where he's like, "Yeah, dude. I was
raped for content that day, so I just
snaked you."
Then he goes, "Just unfortunate that
it's the most interesting thing that
happened on my stream yesterday." So
apparently when Chud snakes you, if his
content sucks for the day, he just
doubles down.
And Chuck, by the way, he'll tell you
he's got no idea why I'm upset about
that.
>> Snaking. Snaking. Yeah, because this is
really embarrassing. Yeah, Nick. This is
really embarrassing, dude. So, this I
guess this was meant to be the we we're
now past the moment where we were
supposed to get the earthshattering res
uh revelation that changes all of our
impression of this. We are now over the
hill, guys. We are supposed to have seen
the vital context that changes our
opinion.
He'll tell you that it's irrational to
be angry that Chud logic in plain
English told me he [__] me.
I mean, that is just [__] outrageous,
isn't it? But I have not put that out
wanting to promote provoke more drama
intentionally, even though it will have
that effect. Oh,
okay. Yeah. I mean, that's a that's a
pretty [__] heavy line, Chud. Then I
said, I'm going to ignore the people
telling me to respond to you. Half
because I really didn't see any reason
to make this a huge [__] thing, and
half because it's so vague. I really
don't know what to say. Anything I'll do
will sound [__] after a three-hour
creator Clash segment. And you might
remember this message. This is the
message that he didn't want to show. I
guess this is the one. Where is it? This
is the one he didn't want to show. Uh
yeah, man. If you want to hop in a call
off stream and really hash some of this
out, we can. It's up to you. I think
that we have more disagreements than
what you're saying. Maybe just have up
to you. I think we have more
disagreements than you're saying. Maybe
Chair and Frank Convo make things
easier, but I'm not looking to fall out
over this. So, I mean, yeah, this is
pretty clear. This is pretty clear. So,
you've made it clear. you're upset over
the public response here.
He's saying, "Well, I still have
disagreements with you. I want to hash
them out with you, so I guess we can do
it off stream.
Maybe having a frank convo will make
things easier. I'm not like to fall out
over this." So, this is just reinforces
my reading of the whole rest of this
conversation.
Like, it it just seems so obvious.
Having a frank combo makes things
easier, but I am not looking to fall out
over this, even though there are many
people that want me to. I'm raped for
content
now. I'm just curious. I didn't go on
and make a [__] public tirade out of
this. I didn't drop this guy in May. I
gave this guy an opportunity to talk to
me. He ghosted me for three months. And
this guy wrote me in DMs telling me that
he felt raped for content. So, he [__]
me.
>> He ghosted you for This was in May. He
ghosted you from September. So, what
happened in those months?
>> I think that's kind of crazy. I think
that's a crazy thing to write somebody.
And I think the issue here is if there's
some misinterpretation that I'm not
understanding, that still also falls on
him. The reason we're talking about this
is because he
>> No, it's pretty clear what happened
here, Nick. Nice try, bro.
>> Started leaking [__] The reason that
I'm even bringing this up now is because
he started leaking [__] To be clear, PP
posted the messages, right? But I
reached out to him and I was
>> This guy's like 29 or some [__] By the
way,
>> have a call about it to clarify what he
said back in May and he [__] ignored
me. So, if there is some weird angle to
these messages that I can't possibly
deduce, he just chose not to talk about
it. And I'm the coward, by the way. I'm
the coward for this. I'm the coward.
So, here are some examples. Hey, hey,
dude. It's been a minute. I hope you're
doing well. Uh me asking if a video is
fake. Yo. And then back to where we are
now. Right. So, this is back in
November. The last message that we had
was like midsepptember, I think.
>> Right. So, that's kind of the stuff that
Chud chose to omit. I've got more stuff
and this this message will still remain
relevant as we move forward. But, I want
to establish a timeline with you because
some people don't understand. Okay,
Nick, Chud [__] you over in May of
last year and you were quiet about it.
You didn't make a huge public issue
about it.
>> [clears throat]
>> or something. So, why is this a problem
now?
>> Well, eagle-eyed viewers would point out
that this message right here, this is
January 14th, 2026 at this point. Yeah,
man. Good luck with whatever you're
doing. I'm fine with just leaving it
there.
>> Is this a joke?
>> I think that this guy [__] me over in
May. I'm not making it a public issue. I
don't really care.
>> Thousand bits for that, by the way.
Thousand bits for that.
>> It's fine. We can move on. I think what
he said on stream was kind of whack, but
fine. Let's move on from there. All
right. Then a couple hours later, my
friend gets accused of domestic
violence, sexual assault, uh pedophilia
down the line, like all these things,
like all these [__] things, right?
And at 8 a.m. the next morning, the
great sweep was on.
>> Yes. Yes. That is the timeline here. I
said, "Hey, man. I'm ready to move on.
We could just go on with our lives." And
then Chudlogic finds out my friend got
accused of rape and then snakes me at
8:00 the next morning.
>> My concern, ladies and gentlemen, is the
big sweep might be on. Okay, the mid the
big snaked me. Watch the clip, guys. My
concern is that the big sweep might be
on.
He snaked me. He snaked me. He stuck a
dagger right into my neck the minute.
[laughter]
Oh my god, the mellow drama. He stuck a
dagger into my neck. What did he say?
Guys, I'm concerned the big sweep might
be on. He suck a dagger in my neck.
[laughter]
Oh my god. Oh my god. I'm dying. I'm
dying.
Where's [clears throat] my DMs with
Nicholas Dioro? Where's my DMs with
Nicholas Dioro?
Here's my DMs. I'm I'm going to link a
DM with Nicholas Dioro. Guys,
>> why is it that anytime that someone
brings up sweeping Nicholas Doro gets
the deep sweats and freaks out over it?
>> Guys, Nicholas Dioro, I can't bother to
because I can't use him anywhere in my
country. Nicholas Dioro said to me in
January of last year, "Hey, by the way,
I don't care if you disagree with me on
or [__] talk on streams." And I said,
"Awesome, man." Oh, I didn't say
awesome. I said, "I saw that tweet
reply, too, heart." because he was
obviously referencing a a tweet reply
where someone was saying, "Why do you
let Cream talk [__] about you?"
>> But yeah, does this does that sound like
the Nick we're hearing here? We stopped
talking. Literally, the minute we
stopped talking, I'm like, "Oh, dude,
it's just it's just the the big sweep.
Why are you bad about being called the
sweeper? My friend's getting accused of
beating women, you [__] son of a
bitch."
Dude, the implication that I would just
ignore my friend doing domestic violence
is like character assassination. That's
like Yeah, that's [__] insane, dude.
Of course. Of course I'd be pissed about
it. be on. Big sweep might be on. Okay,
the mid the big sweep might be on. Okay,
>> but dude, you're more than happy to
ignore other wrongdoings of your
friends. Why would we assume that's any
different? They literally they
aggressively shut down the Kai stuff.
Nick avoided the Willie stuff despite
signaling that he knew the video was
[__]
It's like end they love shutting [__]
down. On top of that, Chud has to know
that I was live while the allegations
were dropping, meaning that I was in
front of an audience doing a show. It is
impossible that I was dual wielding a
live Kiwi Farms thread to know anything
about this when at the end of my stream,
I announced the podcast was on hiatus
because we had an episode dropping the
next day. But he tries to use that to
implicate Tom as guilty.
>> No, he doesn't.
>> I am not participating in the big sweep.
Okay, this is a
>> Why did he try and implicate Tom as
guilty?
legitimate story to cover and talk about
and that's the end of it, bro. And if
anyone disagrees, if anyone thinks I'm
doing something wrong, we'll talk about
it. Okay? Happy to talk about it. But
there is literally nothing wrong with
speaking about this and talking about
this. This is completely legitimate. And
>> so, right here, he brings up another
interesting point.
>> Nicholas Dorian on Twitter. Nick just
responded. Oh, just to be clear, I've
seen
>> Is there anybody on planet Earth who
wouldn't feel backstabbed by this?
nothing of what's occurred tonight, but
my understanding is the halfbaked is on
haters for a little while. So, we'll see
in the next couple of days where that
goes. Okay. And then there's a clip
there. Nick Dur states half baked his
podcast with Tom and Lord Vega is going
on haters for a while. Video's the thing
with this. Okay. Anyone that wants to
claim that this is a nothing burger.
Okay. Why the [__] is the podcast going
on hiatus, dude? So my friend Tom is
guilty because the guy who was live when
the allegations dropped wasn't
>> just like obviously not what's being
said.
Obviously not what's being said. So
blatant, so clear.
Nick is such a dishonest rat.
It's just so obvious. The messaging in
the streams about these allegations was
so clear. There is no evidence for the
worst allegations. They have not
provided substantive evidence for the
actually bad allegations. There's a lot
of smoke about age play. That's got a
bit of smoke. There's a bit of evidence
there,
but most, you know, functional adults
don't actually give a [__] about that.
It's only retards like Nick who are
terrified of their audience, uh, who
give a [__] if their friend of 10 years
is into age play.
Most normal adults would just like kind
of make fun of their friend if they
found that out, you know, or maybe
they'd cut them off if they spoke about
it too much, you know, but the actual
allegations, the substantive allegations
that mattered, there was never any
evidence for and people said as much
there. I mean, well, that's not quite
true. There was some slight
contemporaneous evidence. It just wasn't
actually substantiated. slight
contemporaneous evidence um such as her
talking about bleeding at the time,
right? So that there's stuff like that
that could indicate there's some truth,
but it was never conclusive. It was
never substantiated, you know,
but saying there's no evidence actually
not quite true. That's actually not
quite true. But it was made clear that
it was not substantiated.
Comfortable releasing a video until he
knew it was happening. This is like not
[__] rocket science here. So he's
trying to say because I put the podcast
on hiatus, don't reach out and ask about
it for something serious, by the way.
[__] that [__] Let's just shoot from
the hip.
>> That makes zero [__] sense, bro. That
makes zero sense. Okay, if this is
nothing to worry about, nothing to be
concerned about. Okay, why is
>> he's twisting my statement to say my
friend is guilty
>> podcast going on. Okay, now listen. I
will be fair. I know what people in chat
are thinking and are going to say.
>> Oh, he's fair guys. He's fair.
>> Okay, but my concern, ladies and
gentlemen, is the big sweep might be on.
Okay, the
>> the big sweep is you smearing [__] all
over the [__] place.
>> The big sweep might be on. Okay,
>> bye.
>> I am not participating in the big sweep.
Okay, this is a totally
>> Now, let's dial it back here because
eagle-eyed viewers would point out that
when the time came, Chudlo Logic did say
that Nick Dioro did stream this. So,
what what you're missing here is that
this whole conversation was actually a
shot at a Cheeto. Now, I know he
mentions Hassan [__] and I know he
mentions ETH Idubbbz or whatever, but
this was actually a an interesting
argument that was being levied toward um
sensitive society.
>> It was obviously primarily about Nick. I
think there was a bit of other people in
there, but it was primarily about Nick.
It was mainly about Nick, 100%.
But just because you did cover it after
he said this stuff doesn't necessarily
mean he was wrong to say it. It just
makes it easy for you to do like a
victory lap because viewers are
[__]
>> Except there's one issue with that
>> question, bro. Okay. Now, I don't think
Listen, guys. Okay. Listen. Okay.
[laughter]
I do not believe that people have got an
obligation to cover anything. People can
cover what they want. Okay. But my
question would be, what would the
coverage be like if this is about
Idubbbz? If it was revealed that Idubbbz
that that Ana was into age play and [__]
like that, what would the coverage be?
>> Are you Are you the only Are you the
only one who covers them, Nick?
>> It's literally half the commentary space
that covers these people. This does not
just this does not bolt on your idea
that it's all about you. I say this, it
was primarily about Nick and Chud is
being a [__]
But this is [__]
It was primarily about Nick and Chud is
being a [__] It doesn't make Nick's
argument here any better.
>> Answer to that tells you everything that
you need to know, doesn't it?
>> So, that's that last part that tells you
everything you need to know. That tells
you everything you need to know. And
then here, it's it's there's 20 videos
from Daily Slop channels. But listen to
him here. Listen to the rest of what he
says in the actual stream where this
take was originated from.
>> The answer to that tells you everything
that you need to know, doesn't it?
[laughter]
But nonetheless,
I'm not making any firm claims. I don't
know what's going to happen. I can't
predict the future. I can't predict the
future, guys. Okay? But to me, you can
look at who decides to talk about this
and who doesn't, and that will give you
an indication of what the deal is.
>> Now, people were like, "Nick is
speculatory." This was obviously a shot
at sensitive. Then, here he is in plain
English telling it's about me. It's
about me. It was about me. He literally
told me in plain English it was, "Do you
think I lie to you? Do you think I make
[__] up?"
>> I was responding to your claim of, and
I'm paraphrasing, why would they put the
podcast on hold if it was nothing?
I'm getting a bunch of commentary
drawings coming in saying nothing
burger, no big deal. That's what I'm
saying. If it's no big deal, why is the
podcast on hold? Totally reasonable.
Now, if it's a precaution, so you can
assess, which is reasonable, but that
Yeah, but that still shows it's not a
nothing burger. So, I can agree it's
aggressive to put it in the way I did.
Basically, not everything I say is about
you. N word, but I will say I was
expecting you to not cover this at all
to be totally upfront. Was there
something wrong with my statement I put
out before I went to sleep? So, my
comment about who will cover this and
who won't is a jab at you to be
transparent. Yeah. So this is I think I
think this is totally reasonable. This
is here. Not everything is about you,
but yes, my primary comment was a jab in
your direction. Yeah.
So not everything he said was about
Nick, but the main comment was a jab at
Nick.
So my comment about who will hover this
and who won't is a jab at you to be
transparent. It's [__] He told me He
told me it was about me. You think I
[__] made this up, bro? I had endless
charitability FOR THIS GUY. I WAITED SO
[__] LONG to
>> I won't even say it
>> to expose this guy. Bro,
>> you'll know.
>> DO YOU KNOW HOW MUCH I HAVE PUT UP WITH
WITH THIS [__] GUY? I DON'T WANT TO
leak the DMs. MY WORD IS MY NO, YOU
DON'T WANT TO LEAK the DMs cuz you look
like an [__] I'm getting a bunch of
commentary trullians coming in saying
nothing burger. No big deal. I'm saying
if it's no big deal, why is the podcast
on hold now? It's a precaution so you
can assess which is reasonable. So I
agree it's aggressive to put the damage
is done, you [__] Of of course I'm
mad about this. Basically, not
everything I say about you is about you.
>> It's aggregated is aggressive to put the
why.
All he's saying is it's not a nothing
burger. It's not a nothing burger. That
is why you put the podcast on hold.
But I was expecting you not to cover
this at all to be totally upfront. We'll
get to this. I'm going to show you the
rest of this. Not super relevant, but
again, if I don't release it, he will.
So, let's just go through it. So, my
comment about who will cover this and
who won't is a jab at you to be
transparent. So, that's what he said.
Cool. So, just to be clear, then he got
the video out on January 15th. So,
that's the same is it same day? Yeah,
same like afternoon of the same day. And
then he ran to his little Discord server
and said he's sick of the big sweep and
fired off the uh he got all he got his
entire army in here. How is it that my
video has the most views of this topic?
It's [__] insane. I don't know, dude.
Maybe it's because your video came out
the same day that you streamed about it
at 8:00 in the morning after the
allegations dropped and we're dropping
all night long the night before. Maybe
that is I don't know. Maybe that has
something to do with it. The issue is
that Chud Logic might have been correct.
He might have been correct, but you
can't come out and say the big sweep is
on at 8 am the next morning while the
allegations were going all night.
>> He might have been correct. Nick can not
even with a straight face saying no, it
would have covered this no matter what.
>> Overshot. You've overcommitted to your
point and you look like an [__]
That's the reality of it.
>> So just outing yourself. So yeah, it's
not even that he was wrong. It's just
you can easily make this a science
victory lab.
>> But my issue isn't any of that. I don't
care if his take is bad. My issue is
that he used it to jab a knife into my
back. That's why I was upset personally.
So, there's a few other things that I
want to go through, but before that, I'm
going to be fully transparent with our
DMs on Twitter. So, yes, this is the one
that you've definitely heard about. I
was fuming. I went on there. I saw the
big sweep is on. I realized, holy [__]
this guy and me literally had a fallout
yesterday. He's already stabbing me in
the back. This is unbelievable. So, I
sent him the messages that he showed
you, the uh that not everything has to
come to some catastrophic breakdown. I
know you're used to that. And I said,
"Jesus, dude, yesterday you were saying
[__] like this to me today, and now
you're thrashing me because my friend
got accused of horrific shit." I'm not
really sure how I was supposed to
navigate this stuff better than I did
when I only just found out there were
even allegations at the tail end of my
live show. And to that, Chud said, I
mean, go live and cover it. What? Like
you would with anyone or dude, literally
he's left these till the very [__]
end. Wait, are these out of order? Yeah,
these are totally out of order, bro. Oh
my god. So, he had to jump in midway in
the conversation to make himself not
look like a total [__] [__] here.
Holy [__]
>> Don't if you feel like you're too close
to it, dude. I think that you avoid
stuff that would be negative to cover.
Is that unreasonable? I go, wait, hold
on. So, you're saying that you would
blindfire your friend's Kiwi Farms
thread at midnight while the allegations
are still dropping? Or am I just
misunderstanding you? Like, what is the
argument here? Or do you mean like,
should I go,
>> guys? Don't celebrate 10K. We'll
celebrate 10K when we've cleared it by
like 50 or something and we're not
likely to drop back down. Okay.
>> Life now. Like, what what are we
talking?
>> People subscribe just to chat and stream
and then unsubscribe after the stream
sometimes. today.
Don't don't assume we've hit it. Okay,
that is a great time to remind you guys.
58 people here, 78 likes on stream, some
430 people, and please move the cursor
to thumbs up and clicking or pressing
the thumbs up on the mobile device. That
huge appreciate the 10 gift subs,
Freddy. Thank you. Huge appreciate.
Thank you.
Thank you, Freddy. Thank you. Uh you can
buy membership to the YouTube channel.
Uh sorry, wait, wait. Yeah, like the
stream. That's free. Uh you can donate
by stream elements in the pin chat
message. You can buy a membership to
channel gift membership to channel gift
a whole bunch of memberships around me
throughout the chat. Buy a super chat
which will highlight your message and
readts or buy a super sticker which you
mess it to you. You can go to
discord.gg/quman
screamman or write the comman. Thank
you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you for
the membership apostle. Thank you for
the 10 gifted venomous villain. Hugely
appreciated. Thank you so much. And the
10 gifted from Quella. Thank you so
much. Thank you. Thank you. Huge
appreciate, guys.
>> Talking about here, bro. And then he
goes, I mean, it just feels like I can
never be critical of you in any way
without getting a message from you. Like
you're trying to keep me on my side. Now
he's using the the current talking
points. Then it turns out you do have
this issue with me since May and you
haven't said anything to me about it.
Ch, I asked to chat with you when it
happened and you never got back to me.
And then I kept the line of
communication open. Now eventually Chud
does finally tell the truth that this is
partially his fault when he says, "Yeah,
I could have been more clear on my end,
too. I never wanted to have some big
crash out falling out with you and I
wanted to try and keep things amicable
or neutral because I have no reason to
dislike you and I appreciate what you've
done for me. Why did he not release
these DMs? Yeah, why do you do it?
That's a good point. Um, yeah, I saw
that. That wasn't you, bro. Dude,
sometimes you are very sensitive. I know
it, dude. My friend gets accused of
beating [__] women and Chud goes live
and insinuates that I'm going to sweep
it up and not even cover it, meaning
that I'm pro beating women and he's
like, "Dude, you you're really sensitive
about this, man." That literally that is
such a [__] dude. That literally
mental gymnastics man. Actual mental
gymnastics man. [music]
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
>> You're really sensitive about about
defending your rapist friend. That's
that's really [__] up, man. I mean,
this is like this guy's like comically
[__] So, and also he he pretends he
has no idea why I'm mad at him in his
most recent live stream. I guess he just
didn't read this. Also, I'm not saying
go live and cover unverified
allegations. I get Tom as your friend
and it's a tough spot for you. You
didn't seem to get that in the stream
segment. I think I said on stream it's
hard. You also said a lot of other
things on stream, but it's like the
nature of the beast. Sometimes we are
the hammer and sometimes we are the
nail. That is that is that is a
beautiful statement from dude. Sometimes
we're just that hammer and sometimes
we're just that nail. And even if you
don't want to cover it for personal
reason,
dude,
what is she mad about out there? Thank
you for the 5K. Thank you. You'd
appreciate with the bravo Shibbaenu
clapping super sticker. Thank you. Yeah,
that that's the that's a reasonable
statement. Thank you for the 10 Canadian
dollars. I sue. Thank you with the Shiba
Inu heart super sticker. Thank you.
>> Understandable. That would be viewed
negatively. I go and then at this point
I just [__] I just tell him the
problem and he doesn't even tell me that
I'm wrong. That's the best part.
Everything I'm everything I just told
you for the last 50 minutes or whatever
the [__] I just run him through the
talking points. Chud, my issue with you
is that you said that you hated how
people pit us against each other. Then
you did a segment saying that I'm a
completely compromised Ethan Klein dick
sucker. You uh you reiterated that you
do not watch my streams but asked if I
was loyal to Ethan to a fault. And then
you published that segment fanning the
flames. When I asked why you would
publish a segment if your goal was
actually to avoid people pitting us
against each other, you said you felt
raped for content and it was
unfortunately the only interesting thing
that happened.
>> Yeah. He didn't think it would be a big
[__] deal uploading that [__]
segment. Dude, why would you assume it
would be? Why would you assume it would
be? It's just a segment where he's
spazzing out about RFC mania and then
[__] talks your coverage a little bit.
Why does it have to be a big deal? It
already happened on stream. He'd said
it. They just wanted to post something
that would perform on their channel that
day. You YouTubers, that's the game.
What's the [__] problem
that day? I didn't [__] hide this. I
I said it outright. He just didn't tell
you on the stream the other day. He just
didn't tell you about this in the
segment. By the way, your vague little
shot was open when I'm calling you out.
Then you started talking about [__]
Stardust did. Your response to this was
not uh was what was it? Your response to
this Oh, wait. And your audience thought
it was about me. Your response to this
was it's not all about you or something.
I don't know what issue you think I had
with you. Um, but this is why I was put
off. I do not think that I am being
irrational here. So, what Chunt Logic
does here is what he does every single
time I tried to explain to him what the
problem was. And he just ignores me and
starts crying. So, let's hear about it.
Okay, bro. I understand that. Let me lay
it out. I do have issues with your
What really gets me is Oreo knows that
Chud has a lot going on right now. So,
it's reasonable that Chud would have
forgot to touch base with him. So, why
didn't Oreo reach out to remind him that
he wanted to talk? Such a fairy emoji.
>> Thank you for the $20, Shushon. Thank
you. Huge appreciate. Thanks so much.
>> coverage of certain topics cuz obviously
people want like a big blowout drama
between us. Can Can I just tell this is
before he went on vacation? This is
recent. He he he still didn't want to do
the big blowout. These people want these
like they want this blowout drama
between us and I have a feeling that
you're very resistant to engage with
criticism. You have blocked a lot of the
commentary people over it.
Yeah, I need to read this without the
annoying fsla. Okay, bro, I understand
that. Let me lay it out. I do have
issues of coverage of certain topics.
Obviously, we want to see some big block
drama between us, but the feeling I've
gotten from music you're very resistant
to engage with criticism and have
blocked a lot of commentary people over
it. Totally reasonable. This literally
my reading of this whole situation
totally correct.
I of course have some latent
appreciation for our friendship and have
helped me over the years. So, what do I
do? Some big stream pointing out my
issues, your coverage? I have nothing
personal with you. My lack of commentary
leaves me to get accused of sweeping. So
that's to this is totally reasonable.
It leaves me feeling like I'm biting my
tongue. Sometimes I have a crash out and
talk some [__] and do fan the flames of
[__] as wanting us to fight. I get
that's bothersome for you. You message
me behind the scenes. We don't really
resolve anything. Feels like there are
further tensions and pressures of this
conflict with you which I resist and try
to continue to do my own thing outside
of HD slop cycle. And I of course had
some late and appreciate [__] dude
[__]
ever. Literally ever.
>> This is the most audience captured
[__] I have SEEN IN EVER.
LITERALLY EVER.
>> It leaves me feeling like I'm biting my
tongue. So dude, I'm the [__] You're
afraid of your chat. It leaves me
feeling like I'm biting my tongue
because I have to crash out and talk
some [__] to fan the
>> What? Where is the He's scared of his
chat.
Queen is the ultimate Jew knowing his
top allies struggles with Drake in
donos.
>> He's saying he agrees with a lot of the
criticisms other people have. That's
what he's saying here. He's not saying
I'm saying this cuz I'm scared of ch
saying I'm saying this because I agree
with a lot of it, but there are people
who want it to be the a big blowout.
That's what he's saying.
It's not saying I'm audience capture.
I'm only saying this stuff because my
chat's telling me to. the flames of
[__] wanting us to fight. Now I have
to ask what's the difference between
crashing out and talking [__] so my
[__] chat leaves me alone and the
banter. I'm just curious when he says
it's just bad to me and I I do bad to
all the time but in my messages it's I'M
SCARED OF MY FANS. I'm scared of my
fans.
>> That's literally not what's being said
here.
>> I have to keep them at bay.
>> He he has to like try so hard to twist
this man.
>> I throw the mistakes so they don't eat
me alive.
Dude, Chud, just ignore. Dude, you know
what you should do, Chad? This is the
sort of reading that you can only be
convinced of if you spent
60 plus hours circle jerking about it in
a VC with Tommy C.
My god's honest truth. Me to you. You
should block them. You should block
every last one of them. That's what I
would do. Oh, I have to spare the flames
of [__] who want us to fight. I get
that's bothersome for you. You message
me BTS and we don't ever resolve
anything.
feels like there are further tensions
and pressures for me to have this
conflict with you, which I resist. I try
to continue doing my own things outside
of the HD slop cycle, which has taken
over the commentary space. Alongside
that, I have my own [__] outside of
streaming. I'm dealing with some issues
in my channel that I'm trying to
navigate. Honestly, it feels like a lot
of the communication between us is
keeping up appearances. Obviously,
things have changed and sometimes it
feels like you're just wanting to see if
I'm planning on turning on you. No, you
did. You did turn on me. That's that's
what you did turn on me.
>> Okay, so he's right then. That is what
you were doing.
Okay,
>> so Mr. You're so sensitive. Mr. It's
just banter. Is a complete chat slave
who's terrified of probably Queen. I had
to guess. Probably Queen. Probably
Parry. Maybe even Dickers.
>> Not projecting here, guys. Not
projecting, guys. No projection. Ch's
scared of parry. Not projecting, guys.
He cut Aiden off over Parry. Remember
guys, not projecting. No projection.
He's scared of uh of Queen Barry and
Dickers. That's why Chud anytime would
have me on stream. If we disagree with
something, I guarantee you literally
anytime if I disagree with Chud about
something, I could go on his stream the
next day and fight with him. But yeah,
he's scared. But yeah, he's he's really
scared of me. Okay, man.
Maybe the entire roster of people he was
talking about who he's still friends
with, he's probably scared of you, too.
Yeah. I don't know. Maybe you're not cut
out for this, man. So, we keep going.
Sorry, I read really fast.
>> He's so hurt, dude. He's so [__] hot.
>> Terrified of probably Queman if I had to
guess. Probably Queeman. Probably Perry.
Maybe even Dickers. Maybe the entire
roster of people he was talking about
who he's still friends. He's probably
scared of you too. Yeah. I don't know.
Maybe you're not cut out for this man.
So, we keep going. Sorry, I read really
fast. I'm already through all that. I
don't think I'm ignoring you by typing
fast. But I literally just
>> And you know what else is massive?
>> Sorry. We I I saw the stream went down
for a second, so I hit the massive
button. Nick indirect.
It's actually not me.
>> It leaves me in this place where really
So yeah, just for people who are
returning.
>> FFWN is in is going ahead with full
speed and that is not News Network.
>> Just wish you'd answer any of my
messages and we played a game of
Fortnite and talked about it. I'm I'm
psychotic here clearly. And he goes,
"Just leave me in this place where we
really aren't friends like we used to be
and you're spinning off into the Ethan
orbit and I can't really call it out
without having a massive falling out
with you. But like, do I even need to
call it out? It feels like you're doing
your thing and I'm doing mine." I was
until you acted like I was a comically
evil rape defender who's sweeping up for
Turkey to Tom before I even knew what
the allegations were. [laughter]
That's like Yeah, muted. No, it's not
muted. That's you. It's definitely not
muted.
It's definitely not muted. No, it's you.
I just checked. Thank you. Good troll,
guys. You got me, Chud. Oh, yeah. So
then I say, "Chud, we literally had a
phone call shortly before the
interaction, and I didn't get weird
vibes at all. We were chatting about
EDHD and [__] and going through talking
points, and I missed something." "Yeah,
that was months ago, man." I go, "No, my
point was it was right before the stream
thing." I said, "I was so caught off
guard by you saying that I was loyal to
you."
>> I'm receiving word that JT Stalk would
be going live and taking taking Nick's
side 100%.
>> Fault because we had spoken about this
topic and I didn't realize you thought
that I was a principalist sellout. It
completely caught me off guard, which I
think most people would be a bit bit
perturbed at the concept of their friend
thinking that they have like they've
lost all morals, all morality. So, up
ahead, um, I interpreted at the time as
you being upset that EHD was a content
black hole where no other stories were
getting attention and you were holding
me almost personally responsible. To be
fair, I checked it was 54. Stream thing
was 528. There was some time in between.
I just didn't realize relations broke
down that much in that time frame. So
then he goes, "Dude, what's happening?
Fake Discord messages. This is the only
thing that I'm going to say my bad
over." I told And when Chudlo Logic
started doing his whole the big sweep is
here thing, I was like, "Bro, this is
crazy. We literally had a falling out."
>> Dude, it's literally like the [__]
It's like a like [__] rape victim
support group. Unironically,
I said years ago that Child Logic is a
spotless snake and face faced endless
targeting for it. despite saying my
piece and moving on. I was a fixation of
him and his crew for years. Let's see
he's facing the music now. Stardust, you
are a punching bag because you're a
total [__] laughing stock.
>> Yesterday. So obviously his little drone
started posting it. So that is Where are
we? Yeah. So that goes up. I said,
"Yeah, I didn't say anything specific in
my Discord. I just were not cool
anymore." I shouldn't have said
anything. My bad. Uh I was just blown
away when I clicked into
>> Think about this, guys. Think about
this. She says this about how how Chud
targeted her and I targeted her and
everyone targeted her. She had said all
that to Nick. She had said how terrible
it was, how much it upset her, how much
it caused her to have her little OCD
spiral that she's got because of
whatever you terrible thing happened to
her as a child. She said all this to
Nick behind the scenes. Said how
terrible it was, how scary it was that
he was associating with me back when he
first started associating with me and he
ignored her. He basically told her to
kick rocks.
Thank you for the membership, CRTV.
Thank you. your stream to hear about the
Tom [__] and you were just unloading on
me right after we stopped talking
yesterday. So, and I apologize for that.
He goes, "Okay, I mean, haha, I was
taking some shots though." Yeah, it's
definitely what I'd call it, but uh like
I have to respond to what I see in front
of me. The board uh thrust was why is
the podcast on hiat on hold if it's no
big deal? I mean, you could use common
sense. I think that you have access to
that ability. That is an ability that
you I believe do have. And then Chud
said, "Okay, I mean, haha, I was taking
some shots." That's the one we just
read. Yeah, Chud, I was live. I thought
it was insane. I don't have time to even
read the thread. I was being
precautionary. He goes, "Oh, I'm not
saying go live and put them on blast
immediately," which is kind of what it
sounds like considering the timeline for
this is the next day. So, when would you
have wanted me to do that? At 8 a.m. I
mean, the claims aren't well evidenced
anyway so far. I go, "No, I mean, I was
already live at the time." He goes, "Be
real, dude. You know that he won't get
hold over the cold for like for this
like it was Idubbbz or Hassan." I go,
"To answer your question, no, I did not
know anything. I didn't even know what
he was fully accused of until I ended
stream. I went a lengthy rant on the
stream about uh going in on unverified
claims with Hassan and the furry thing."
So yeah, I wanted to put out the podcast
on hold in case Tom turned out to be a
sexual predator. We had an episode ready
to drop today. Okay, man. We're getting
lost in translation here. So I whipped
that back. I whipped that back and I
said I was responding to your claim. And
I'm paraphrasing of why would they put
the podcast on hold if it was nothing.
So then Chud starts complaining saying
I'm getting a bunch of commentary drool
coming in saying nothing burger. No big
deal. So I'm saying it's no big deal.
Why is the podcast on hold? Now it's a
precaution which is reasonable. So I
agree it's aggressive to put it in the
way that I did. Basically not everything
I say about is about you nword. But I
will say I was expecting you not to
cover this at all to be totally upfront.
And then he said, "So my comment about
who will cover this and who won't is a
jab at you to be transparent." So I sent
him my initial statement and I go, "Did
this get leaked?" I think I missed a
message, but it wasn't super relevant,
but I want to make sure it's here. Or
maybe I didn't. No, I didn't. I don't
think I didn't. So here we are. Um,
where was something wrong with statement
I put out? Um, no, not necessarily, but
be real with me, dude. We're dealing
with a different approach to this versus
Idubbbz and Assan. That being said, I
know you criticized Willie Msho for
spreading unverified [__] I think I am
missing a message. I do not want to take
him out of context. Give me two seconds.
I'm grabbing it because that was a
mistake on my part. It should be Chud
message two or three. Chud message two.
Is it this?
Um, yes, this is the one we're missing.
I'm sorry. I missed one ear. I missed
the second message. So, I do not want to
take him out of context. Um, it was I
mean, I feel like I can never be
critical of you in any way without
getting a message from me. Like, you're
trying to keep me on your side. Then, it
turns out I do have this issue since
May. You haven't said anything to me
about it. By the way, you know, I was
literally [__] on Willie M show for
his Assassand take, like the horrific
Assant take about a furry account
yesterday. I caught that jab, too. Then
he says, "Yeah, I saw that. It wasn't
pointed at you, bro. Sometimes you're so
sensitive. I know it's tough and
whatnot." I said, "Chud, I asked to chat
with you and all this [__] happened. You
never got back to me. I kept the line of
communication open." I actually think I
just missed that one message, but I
wanted to make sure I didn't [__] that
up. Sorry. So, moving forward, um, it
should be Yes, this is this is the one
we're on. Yep. Good. They all look the
same. [laughter]
>> Yeah. Wouldn't this be easier? went
through all the messages in
chronological order instead chopping up
to try and present some gay little
narrative that just totally falls apart
if you actually read the messages
>> fairly. But be real with me, dude. We're
dealing with a different approach to how
Idubbbz or Hassan would be handled. That
being said, I know you've criticized
Willie Mac Show for spreading unverified
[__] My take is if it's a nothing
burger, I won't cover it. If he's done
something, I will. But I want to wait
until um I want to wait because I think
I'm too biased to cover it when it's
breaking news. And then he goes, "Okay,
but and this is not unreasonable. He's
getting a lighter touch because he's
your friend." I thought this was
obvious. I thought for anybody this
would be obvious. Yes, it is more
difficult to be critical of severe
allegations against somebody that you've
hung out with that's like been your
friend for seven years. Yeah, like of
course, of course that's the case.
That's literally why I opened my segment
telling you that was the case when I
eventually did my stream. Then he says,
I'm not trying to catch you out here,
just trying to be real. I wrote I wrote
that directly. I am compromised because
he is my friend. I am fully ready to
condemn him if he is guilty, but I do
not trust myself to be able to fully
separate from this. I think that a
segment where things are unverified will
be a lot of embarrassing coping because
I'm subconsciously looking for excuses.
This is what I told you when I covered
it. So that is Dude, this is literally
[laughter]
He's reading this. He's reading this in
this is the point. This is the point.
Yes, you're in just sweep. You're you
sweep you and your friends [__]
sweep. Oh, I think it would be easier to
navigate once all of the allegations are
made because they were spoon feeding it
and dripping it.
>> Finally, if I cover this, I'm going to
sweep and then people going to call me a
sweeper will sweep for their friends if
they've got rape allegations.
>> But you are. That is what you're saying.
That's what you are.
>> Drip feeding it. And not as breaking
news as things are being dripfed. I do
not think there is any shame in
admitting publicly and privately that
it's going to be harder for me to
navigate when one of my close friends
gets accused of heinous [__] I do not
think this is controversial. If Chide
Logic does, it explains why he has no
friends. That's the reality of the
situation. Maybe to delusional
four-year-old retards, uh, this is a
foreign concept, but for people who
actually do have friends, I think that
most of them would understand my
position.
>> I mean, I'm in a different boat.
>> Friends, as in some guy on the other
side of the world that you only know
through YouTube,
as if this friendship should be treated
the exact same as every other
friendship. No, obviously the content
element to the friendship and you're
doing a job at the same time. You
[__] idiot, dude.
Cuz none of you and we're I'm in a
different boat because you guys don't
even like me anymore. Although it's
different between us. I was more than
fair. I have no issue with you covering
it. I was actually looking to watch your
coverage today to see some of it for the
first time. But obviously, yeah, it's
hard to navigate. I clicked in during
the great sweep. I I was going to you
for unbiased coverage. Haha, bro. I'm
being real as [__] right now. That's not
just about you. None of the cabal will
cover this. This is [__] hilarious. I
am the cabal. WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE CABAL, [__] YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT ME. THERE'S NOBODY ELSE, which he
agrees with. So when you say the cabal,
Chudlo logic, are you talking about
sensitive society? Are you talking about
a cheeto? Are you talking about think
before you sleep? Are you you're talking
about [__] me?
>> [__] you, man.
>> I be friends I would not be friends with
this guy if he [__] begged to get
down on his knees and suck my [__] after
this. [__] this guy, bro. Oh,
>> I didn't do a sex. You always sound so
rapey, bro. Dunk.
>> Never say anything about sex on your
live stream, Nicholas. We don't want to
hear it. We don't want to hear that
[__] Go straight to prison.
>> I do plan on covering this though. I
just want to cover it when things are
all out in the open. Dude, you
unfollowed me? Yeah, I was pissed then
refollowed. Bro, I was [__] mad.
Dude, the issue here is the underlying
tension. Some of which isn't even about
you. I love the vague like, Listen,
dude. Clearly, I have tons of problems
with you, but I hate other people, too.
Yeah. People [laughter]
see things like that aren't like what
they were. I am a I'm a strange people
want resolution to this tension. They
don't want BTS combos. They want blood.
I hope you understand that when you only
say my name and then you is that when
you only say my name or make a comment
about Ethan Klein.
>> That's just true. What is the problem?
I'm failing to see the problem with any
of that. Yes, you are content friends.
If you disagree over content, it should
be content. That's what the audience
wants. That's what you should want.
That's what's best.
>> Your audience will think it's about me.
That's like so obvious. So, it's such a
copout to say, "Oh, I'm talking about
other people." Bro, you [__] name me
to try to get the piranhas off your
back. You're scared of your chat.
>> So, you can't just sit here and say,
"No, I I didn't mean no harm. I didn't
mean no harm." It's like, no, you're
obviously taking digs to try to keep
them at bay. It's pathetic. Your
audience captured pathetic.
>> Um, so then he says, "Yeah, 100% it's
about you. Thanks, dude. I make jabs
about other creators all the time.
They're not jabs. They're not playful
jabs. They're barely They're literally
just like human sacrifices being put to
demons.
>> Like
>> listen to how [__] cut off he gets of
this [__] bro.
Look, dude. I l I can't I think this
guy's called me a pedophile about 600
times. This This Ch guy. This Chud guy's
called me a pedophile about 600 times.
You're making serious allegations of
sweeping. Please get a grip. get a grip.
And the moment he went on holiday, guess
what I was doing? I was sitting on
stream saying, "This guy's getting child
prostitutes in Vietnam. This guy's this
guy's a divorce, which he's not going to
Asian country to have sex with children.
It's not a big deal. It's not a big
deal. It's banter, dude. It's banter."
>> I talked about JTO having Destiny's
sloppy seconds.
>> Or I talk [__] about his right-wing
chat. I talk [__] about his right-wing
chat and his immigration takes. Like
those those are probably more comparable
complaints, you know? Those are more
comparable complaints here, you know?
It's just not a big deal. It's not a big
deal. Nick takes it as a massive [__]
deal because Nick can't take the
conflict. Nick can't take the chat. Nick
can't take the Reddit. That's why he's
on H3 snark all night reading comments
about himself and then sending them to
people.
>> Listen, when he's right, he's right.
It's pretty based. Um, you keep saying
it's about all these people. Even with
the Stardust thing earlier, I don't
remember if this is accurate, so I don't
want us to date it as a fact. It was
shot from the hip in a DM conversation.
I don't remember if he says Stardust. I
remembered it the other way, but just to
be clear, I'm not trying to take him out
context. I think sometimes that that you
think you're doing me a favor. I don't
believe that. I think he's a coward. Uh,
and it makes the situation worse. I
don't know, dude. We're going in circles
here, and I think we already touched on
the more significant issues. So, he
goes, "The only way this will be
resolved is by a combo in public. I
don't know any other way, but I will be
using lethal force, and you will have to
defend yourself." I go, "You think the
best course of action is to litigate our
DMs on stream and scream at each other?"
I guess that I guess that turned out to
be the way it works. But I mean, I think
it's stupid. I think all this is stupid
to be honest. I I don't I
>> literally because you can't take the
conflict. You can't take it.
>> [__] I feel like a total [__]
loser addressing the friendship
allegations cuz a stupid British
40-year-old [__] lied about me publicly
on stream and put me in a position where
I had to explain what happened.
>> It's not about the friendship
allegations. Obviously, it about your
actual disagreements, dude.
>> I mean, I'm not sitting here doing
emotions and feelings. I'm just showing
you what he said. You can call it cope.
You can call it whatever you want. The
reality is all of the stuff that I'm
showing you is just his words and I'm
just showing you what he said. Tell you
what, if you have huge issues with my
coverage on Tom when the time comes, I
might humor that, but I won't be
subjecting myself to a gay debate on the
friendship allegations. So, there's that
one. Where are we?
Um,
did I miss it? Boom. There it is. Okay,
then we're at the tail end of this part.
No, dude. About it all. About EHD, the
clubhouse. I don't know what the
clubhouse is. The Cabal, Tommy, Willie
Mack Show, Tommy C, the whole lot. Rate
mode on. I go, "Oh, okay. You're meing
because I thought that was like
obviously a joke." Which he then says,
"Yeah, it is somewhat." Sorry I didn't
pick up on that sooner.
>> It's like playful. It's playful, but
yes, he's pushing you to have a
conversation.
>> 12 hours, but I didn't know how else we
were going to resolve the contradiction.
I was under the impression yesterday
that you had no intention of resolving
this. I thought that you were totally
fine with just us not talking. So, I
didn't know we were looking to resolve
anything.
>> That's not that was obviously not the
point there. Again, he is like it is so
delusional. You have to be literally
autistic to take Nick's reading here.
>> We're moving on. That's like not what I
was That wasn't what I signed up for in
this conversation. Well, yeah, because I
don't want a big fight with you. Well,
it sounds like now you do. Uh, and it's
But you're trying to tell your audience
you seemingly always did, but you're
also not mad about the sub loss, but you
also are terrified to fight with me or
something. Yeah, this is really
embarrassing. I do appreciate our
friendship, what you've done for me, but
I make a jab, give a take, and that's
the issue. I don't talk about you and I
get pressed for sweeping. So, this is
another moment where Chad Logic is
admitting he's a cowardly [__] who's
strong month education in Durham on
traditional mining and structural
reinforcement methods so he can dig
through Nick's hundreds of cubic meters
of fat folds to find his willie and earn
back his friendship.
>> Thank you for the $3. Thank you.
>> Terrified of being called a sweeper
while constantly calling people
sweepers.
>> I mean, dude, if you're in my shoes, I
don't care if you hate me or like me or
what you thought about me before the
stream, but would you not be spinning?
Is this not [__] crazy? Why does he
keep saying
>> I would just get on a stream and argue
with him. I would I would recognize that
we've got disagreements about content in
public.
>> So I would have the public conversation
and argue it down.
He's terrified of his chat calling him
sweepers and then keep calling everybody
sweepers. The reason why the destiny
sweeper thing was so malicious is
because there's an entire Kiwi farms of
people going after every single person
who who sweeps for Destiny if you if you
give them that label. Because if you
swap for Destiny, you're ontologically
evil and you get applied to like rape
defender, uh, nude exchange, like all
that's like everything that Destiny's
ever been accused of, you're just
totally down with it. If they brand you
a Destiny sweeper, you're ontologically
evil. But in this case, it's just like,
you don't even want to be called the
sweeper for not talking about Ethan
Clyde. That's like actually pathetic.
>> So then I just explain to him my final
thoughts. Uh, dude, the issue is the jab
and the take is that I'm totally
unprincipled and a dick sucker
organizing a mass sweep for my accused
friend to shut down people like you. I
feel like you realize I take offense to
that characterization.
Support
for Chud is pivotal right now.
>> Uh, this is absolutely true. I don't
know if you organize a mass sweep for
your accused friend. That's not quite
there. But yeah, totally on principal
dicks sucker. That is absolutely true.
>> I'm like comically malicious in your
interpretation. It's not like I've ever
>> It's not like comically malicious.
You're like an avoidant self-interested
[__] I think that's pretty clear.
>> Reached out to you over every Sorry.
It's not like I've reached out to you
>> again. You know, so someone's
self-reporting like crazy when they do
this. Oh, you think I'm like some evil
mastermind just being like totally
malicious evil master? You're
self-reporting.
>> For every minor comment, which he didn't
push back on, but told everybody was the
case. Anyway, I I was confused when you
say that I'm a horrible person because
that's what a unprincipled fraud would
be is a horrible person. I didn't know
that my friend thought that I was a
total complete dick sucking sellout. So,
I was bit shocked to have that
information shared with me. Regardless,
I'm sympathetic to you getting it from
both sides here as well. I don't really
care. In the future, say whatever you
want. So, that was the way that that
ended. Now, there's a couple more things
that I do want to address before I'm
done tonight. This is a clip that he
just
>> responded to him.
>> He just lied here. Let me show you this
one.
>> And then I made some comments about him
to Pisco. Do you remember that?
>> I made I made some comments to Pisco
about how much Nick blocks people and
that I felt
>> so now he's leaning into his audience's
talking points here as if I give a [__]
about being called out for blocking.
I've been doing this for like seven
years. This is my position. Deal with
it. Subscribe. Don't get the [__] out. I
don't really care. But he's trying to
lean into a lot.
>> He doesn't care, guys. He doesn't care.
He doesn't care, guys. He's so above it
all. That's what he's crying about on
stream right now.
>> And guess what I got when that started
getting shared on social media.
>> You got actually nothing because you're
[__] and leaked the DMs where I told
you what I was mad about. If you
actually correlate this clip and what
he's saying right here, I'm talking
about how you said that you don't like
us anymore. And I'm surprised that you'd
say something like that cuz you ghosted
me since September. So, he fabricated
this entire angle that I'm mad about
some Pisco conversation. Unfortunately
for Pisco, he's kind of just like a
casualty of this conversation because I
have no issue with him. The issue with
the clip that I had is this one
>> recorded against my rules.
>> So why did you block him? So we're going
to hear a very reasonable expl to why
Pisco is blocked here then, aren't we?
>> It wasn't like anything beyond that.
Queman is is Queman like your friend.
>> Well, you tell me, dude. You've spoken
to him more recently on a voice call
apparently. So you tell me, right?
>> Well, you're both British. I'm told that
Queman comes from your community. That's
what people tell me. He does, but I've
had to cast him out because, you know,
he's uh unfortunately been too attack.
He's a Hassan fan. He's gone after all
the commentary guys and they don't like
me anymore.
>> So, I said it's kind of weird to say
that all the commentary guys don't like
you anymore because of Quean, which this
could be multiple people as well, but I
wrote back asking, "Hey, why are you
saying that I don't like you anymore
considering you've been ghosting me
since September?" It's
>> Yeah, I mean, obviously Tommy C and
Willie, that's certainly a huge factor.
Now, Nick can act like that's not a
factor for him. I think he's uh very
clearly revealing in this stream that
that is among other things a factor. But
for Willie Mack, Tommy C, that's
absolutely Yeah. Yeah. Tommy has said as
much,
Willie has made a whole video about it.
That's absolutely true. So when Chard
says, "Oh, the commentary guys don't
like me anymore." That's it's absolutely
correct.
It's totally totally reasonable to say.
>> Obvious that this is what I was saying.
It's like verbatim, but if you want to
look at it here, it's the commentary
guys don't like me anymore. So, I wrote
you just ghosted me. [laughter]
Like, that's just [__] crazy. That's
an insane thing that you did. Um, also,
yeah, this is just the context of those
messages, too. I said that you haven't
answered me since September because u he
hadn't answered me since September, just
for your viewing pleasure. Lastly,
there's this clip.
>> It's not a safe space. Your friends put
a bot on my server and put my paid
Discord on a public website. Miss one.
Should I just
>> stop stealing his screen discord
screenshots now? Stop stealing his
Discord screenshots. What the [__]
dude? This is unbelievable.
>> Oh, what the [__] I was almost done
with my thing. Anyway, all right. So,
for that clip, he's telling me that I'm
[__] stealing his screenshots or
something. Let me just not my
intellectual property.
>> Is it going to reopen? Oh, it reopened.
Okay.
>> It's not.
>> All right.
>> I don't I thought that, you know, Well,
there were public links to that Discord.
Wasn't there like a waiting room where
you had to be verified by a moderator of
the Discord and the moderator had to let
you in to see the channels? Isn't that a
thing?
>> A safe space. Your friends put a bot on
my server and put my paid Discord on a
public website. Oh my god, dude.
>> So, he's reading this and he's like,
Nick Dioro, the guy from the commentary
community, is horrified of screenshots.
Bro, do you think that I am embellishing
this? You're [__] maybe not your guy,
but I think he might even talking about
it in your server. Some guy created a
bot, put it in my paid server, connected
it to a [__] website. This is not a
screenshot. It's a live leak of every
message that gets posted on my paid
server. My paid
>> a live leak.
>> I wish,
>> but I think you might even talking about
in your server. Some guy created a bot,
put it in my paid server, connected it
to a [__] website. This is not a
screenshot. It's a live leak of every
message that gets posted in my paid
server of all my paid members supporting
my channel. I don't care if if you're
screenshotting it. That's like, okay,
whatever. They are mirroring my entire
server. And you know, you know
[laughter] who knew that? Well, Chad
here, cuz he's reading a message where I
verbatim say it. Now, this was
inevitably taken down. Woo! Awesome. Uh,
I think Aiden spread like a rumor that I
was trying to sue the guy who did it. I
don't know if this is like a [__]
[__] position or what. I I don't own
Discord. I can't sue you for putting my
members server on a website. That's
stupid. I just wanted it down because
that's kind of crazy and it's like a
like are we going to start like
individually parsing the guys who give
me money next? Is that the next thing
that we're going to do because you got
to hate me that much? Is that the plan?
Like what's what's going on here? So I
was like, "Yeah, dude." Oh, you're in a
safe space on Discord. I'm not
>> Oh, so Nick's uh Nick's playing [__]
games here as well. He's being dishonest
here cuz I think while Aiden did float
the idea of it being a lawsuit, the main
point that was being made is that Nick
was begging Dan Saltman to help him with
it. That I think that was the main point
that was being made in Aiden's statement
there, Nick.
I think that was actually the main thing
that was being said there
in a [__] safe space, [__]
You dude, your [__] fans are doing
this [__]
>> Stop stealing his screenshot. Discord
screenshots now. Stop stealing his
Discord screenshots.
>> He's got it in front of him and he just
lies to you. He just lies to your face
straight away. So that's the Orio Rodeo.
And then this is the last thing.
Unfortunately, this is the only thing
that I can't prove to you definitively
because it's entirely fabricated. It
just didn't happen. But I will preface
something. This is what I'm going to say
about this allegation. one after having
been subjected to some deranged [__]
attack against my credibility whilst I'm
on holiday and I'm the finest one
apparently. What the [__]
How about addressing the questions
people are asking instead of just
calling the [__] What do you mean
I'm addressing the questions? Dude,
>> I'm sorry. I was trying to pull up the
clip that I wanted, but I got more of
him yelling in the chat. I'm sorry,
dude. I'm sorry. I I I actually didn't
mean to do this. My the [__] restart
[__] me up. I didn't mean to put more.
Wonderful.
>> Thank you for the super chat. Thank you,
>> dude. He's got to stop being so
sensitive, man.
>> [clears throat]
>> Didn't you also signal boost the Assan
crews cancel culture alleg? This is
clearly not what I wanted. Hold on. Let
me just get it quick. I know where to
find it. Um,
if we can grab it. What the [__] What
the [__] What happened? Why are we full
screen, bro? I'm I'm a professional
streamer. I promise you. This stream
went so well up until the very last
second for non-scripted. This is
actually [__] Banger memes by Nick
Dioro.
>> I'm the spineless one.
>> Actually, does it count if it's
scripted? If I No, then every stream
will be scripted. This is the way I do
every stream. Um, so this is how you
know I'm live, by the way. Hello to
Jinro777 with the Katamoshi. I
appreciate you if you hate me or don't.
Um, so this the one that
[laughter]
I'm crying. I'm crying.
Oh my god.
I'm looking for here is planned.
Planned.
Well, that would be plaid. But this if I
No, then every stream would be scripted.
This is the way I do every stream. Um,
so this is how you know I'm live, by the
way. Hello to Jinro777 with the cat
emoji. I appreciate you if you hate me
or don't. Um, so this the one that I'm
looking for here is planned. [snorts]
Planned.
Well, that would be planned. Planned.
Sorry, the microphone's over the
keyboard. So I'm looking for the one
where he says planned. Yeah, this is it.
This is the
>> But it does. It does. It Yeah, it
probably was planned. It probably was
planned. It probably was planned.
What Chad's referring to here is he
thinks that my friend Turkey Tom whose
multi-million dollar channel and career
was on the line where he would get
branded as like a [__] sex offender
for the rest of his life. Um that he
delayed his video intentionally to spite
Chud on vacation as like a gift to me.
Or maybe he's just horrified of the 14k
viewers Chud's going to get. Let me just
ease your tensions on this one. I'm not
trying to get out of it. I'm not trying
to hide anything. It's just not what
happened. Unfortunately, it would be
really funny if it was true because that
would mean that Chudlogic went on
vacation for two weeks, which is
identical to the amount of time that I
couldn't respond to Chud Logic without
[__] over my friendship with Turkey
Tom because Turkey Tom still had to
respond to his allegations. So, it is
very funny. Um, and it is very funny
that it happened while Chud was on
vacation. And I wish I thought of it,
but I didn't. So, that's my position on
that. You can believe it or not believe
it, but ultimately,
>> okay, well, when Jay pressed Ogie about
it, Ougie went, I don't know. Charge is
pretty quick to accuse people of
sweeping. That's what Ogie said. So, I
mean, take that as you will. Take that
as you will.
>> If it was true, I'd be okay with it. It
just didn't happen that way. Turkey Tom
was getting accused of a various amount
of things. You can go read the Kiwi
Farms thread. Uh Sacramento just kept
going all weekend long. That is likely
the reason why the video didn't get
released on the planned whatever day it
was actually going to come out because
when you keep drip feeding things, you
don't know if you're going to have to
make three videos or one video. The
intention is to make one definitive
video. And I think any reasonable person
would come to that conclusion. But Chud
Logic is not a reasonable person.
>> Planned.
>> He's almost as unhinged as YMS. No,
dude. Tud logic goes to this
>> [__] He goes to this
>> Dude, this is like Flamco. This is like
Bob Black. This is like tipster. This is
like uh this is like
what's the other Suzie Lou? This
[laughter] Vietnamese brothel, okay,
every single year his fans know that he
goes to this trans Vietnamese brothel
every single year, dude. And [__]
stupid Rob's Media has come out. I'm I'm
kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm
kidding. It's a joke. It's a joke. It's
a joke. I'm making a YMS joke.
>> You sound mad.
Um
>> it's [__] YMS's stupid movie convent.
Sorry. Sorry. Right, dude. Current Nick
just jumped over [__] retro 2022 Nick
Dioro. My bad. I Current Nick just
jumped out of me. Sorry.
>> I think it's just frustrating really.
It's just frustrating to witness such
cowardice.
>> So yeah, this is it. Chloic leaked a DM
that had no context cuz his chat bullied
bullied him into it and then I had to
provide the rest of the content that I
was perfectly fine with kind of just
letting
>> Yeah, I'm not going to lie. The rest of
the context kind of makes SH look
better. I kind of expected he would be
more avoidant in DMs, but no, he's
clearly raising the idea of disagreeing,
raising the idea of going on stream, and
you were clearly communicating that you
feel hurt by the fact that he's spoken
about this stuff and don't want to have
a conversation. That's clearly what's
happening.
Well, until he decided to shank me in
the back minutes after. [laughter]
I think this is just really shitty.
Yeah, I think it's really shitty. Oh,
dude, why is this different than all of
the other I was reading through the
Reddit post and people were like, "Dude,
Chud does this to Nick all the time. Why
is this one different?" It's like, yeah,
because you think I'm an unprincipled
sex offender sweeper.
>> Sure. That's like a really that's like a
ontologically evil position to be in. So
ultimately, what what does this mean?
What does it
>> Dude, you just hear it, don't you, man?
You hear the the You hear it all the
time. You just can't escape it.
>> Please explain J6 to me. Please explain
J6. Please explain Tenant Media to me
for the channel. After this, we're going
back to covering trending news coverage.
Uh, this community is [__] gonzo. No
remorse. Same thing I said during the
Galvo Edwin stuff. Uh, I'm never talking
to Chad Logic again. I think warranted.
I think that's a warranted position that
I'm having. Um, and yeah, that's that's
probably the last time I will ever
address this. The first and last time.
It's nice. It's wrapped in a bow. And
you'll see the segment tomorrow. Uh,
[__] this guy. [__] the community that
controls this guy. [__] his friends.
[__] his family. [__] the entire Great
Britain as a whole. I'm I should have
known better than to trust an English
YouTuber. I respected this guy
immensely. The way that he navigated his
destiny.
>> Oh my god.
Thank you for the $5. Thank you.
>> Drama to defend DK editing. I thought he
was one of the most principled people
I've ever interacted with. I was clearly
wrong. [laughter] This guy totally
sucks. And this is why I hate Chud
Logic. So, ladies and gentlemen, I don't
even
>> What is he showing throughout this?
Like, [__] nothing. Like, Chud's
saying that he simultaneously disagrees
with Nick and wants to hash it out with
him, but also doesn't want to turn it
into a massive personal blow up, which
is like exactly what Ch has said a
million times over. And you are being a
pathetic fur about it.
Okay.
>> [__] hilarious.
>> Great.
Cool, man. Awesome. That's sick.